[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour le moment fort du
mercredi au sénat les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
à 15 heures les sénateurs vont enterrer
ou interroger les ministres sur les
sujets du moment et on parlera notamment
de l'allègement des mesures sanitaires
puisqu'il ya quelques minutes le premier
istres jean castex a annoncé à la fin du
couvre-feu à 23h à partir de dimanche
prochain
également la fin de l'obligation de
porter le masque en extérieur on va vous
faire vivre cette séance de questions
d'actualité avec toute notre équipe du
mercredi est d'abord notre commentateur
situé en tribune de presse de
l'hémicycle du sénat
quand un calme et bon jour alors quel
est le programme aujourd'hui
et bien justement alexis devait y avoir
deux questions pour s'interroger sur et
bien ces étapes du déconfinement ou le
masque en extérieur mais les sénateurs
vont donc changer de fusil d'épaulé on
attend beaucoup de sujets la justice
l'hôpital public l'immigration ou encore
le nucléaire
aujourd'hui au programme mais merci
quand ans et puis nous serons avec notre
interviewer situé dans la salle des
conférences du sénat il recueillera les
réactions des ministres des sénateurs
bonjour steve jourdain bonjour alex
bonjour à tous alors qui allez-vous
avoir votre micro cet après midi
beaucoup de monde alex on demandera
notamment aux élus ce qu'il pense
précisément et bien de ces annonces de
jean castex
mais oui on a envie d'avoir ces
réactions à l'allègement des mesures
sanitaires
on ira voir également notre streamer
politique jean massiet qui commande
cette séance de questions d'actualité
sur sa plateforme switch avec sa
communauté
salut gens commencent à voir saluer l'ex
j'espère que ça va pour toi aussi écoute
on a hâte de voir cette séance de
questions d'actualité
seulement une heure après les annonces
tant accompli tôt jean castex est qu à
14h30 on parlera du projet loi
antiterroriste qui est examinée en ce
moment au sénat est une nouvelle étape
dans la lutte contre
terrorisme ce sera l'objet de notre face
à face entre la sénatrice écologiste
sofitel polian et le sénateur les
républicains marc philippe daubresse
mesdames mais d'abord on va s'intéresser
à la campagne des élections régionales
et départementales puisque le premier
tour a lieu dimanche prochain une
campagne pleine de polémiques de tension
de violence même pour en parler
j'accueille aujourd'hui sur ce plateau
jany kalemie bonjour vous êtes
rédactrice en chef adjointe au service
politique du parisien aujourd'hui en
france
jacques également si ward show
sociologue consultant pour l'institut de
sondage viavoice bonjour bonjour
et puis également sur ce plateau chloé
ridel vous êtes directrice adjointe de
l'institut rousseau bonjour et puis nous
serons également à distance avec
virginie martin politologue
bonjour bonjour alors avant de parler
des élections régionales je voudrais
vous faire réagir sur l' annonce qui a
eu lieu il ya quelques minutes celle du
premier ministre jean castex avec un
allègement des mesures sanitaires
ce sera à la fin du couvre-feu à 23h à
partir de dimanche prochain également la
fin du port du masque en extérieur on va
écouter jean castex le port du marx
anesthésie heures ne sera donc plus
obligatoire sauf dans certaines
circonstances quand on se regroupe
quand on se trouve dans un lieu bondé
une files d'attentes sur un marché ou
encore dans les tribunes d'un stade
les arrêtés préfectoraux qui régissent
le port du masque en extérieur seront
donc modifié dès demain pour traduire
cette nouvelle règle de bon sens on
regarde l'évolution de la situation
épidémique
deuxième évolution le couvre-feu à 23
heures qui devait vous le savez
s'appliquer jusqu'au 30 juin cessera de
s'appliquer à compter de ce dimanche
soit dix jours avant la date prévue
janick halimi ce déconfinement avant la
date prévue comme l'annoncé jean castex
est ce que c'est un succès au final pour
la stratégie des confinement du goût
demande emmanuel macron en tout cas
politiquement c'est évidemment ce
qu'espère le gouvernement et l'exécutif
en général on se souvient que emmanuel
macron en janvier avait surpris un peu
tout le monde parce que au regard de ce
qui se passait dans les autres pays
européens qui rend confinait à c'est
assez durement la france elle avait
préféré enr confinement certes mais
light emmanuel macron avait été
extrêmement controversée à l'époque y
compris par une partie de la du corps du
corps médical donc c'est vrai qu'il y
avait eu un risque en janvier et là en
annoçant avant la date la levée de
plusieurs des mesures symboliques de
ceux de se re confinement le
gouvernement sait qui va faire une
démarche extrêmement populaire tout le
monde en a envie
deuxièmement donc comme vous le disiez
je pense que ça veut acté la réussite de
la politique sanitaire entre guillemets
original d'emmanuel macron cela dit il
prend tout de même des risques parce que
quand on voit ce qui se passe en
angleterre notamment au contraire boris
johnson prolonge d'un mois leur
confinement dans lequel la grande
bretagne était été placée on peut
espérer que l'exécutif c'est ce qui fait
parce que s'il devait revenir en arrière
dans quelques semaines là ce serait
terrible
chloride elle est ce que c'est un succès
cet allègement des mesures sanitaires
avec cette stratégie originale
d'emmanuel macro comme jenny cali me l'a
dit c'est à dire de trouver un compromis
entre le respect des libertés est
également l'impératif sanitaires c'est
une réussite
je sais pas si c'est un succès mais en
tout cas c'est une bonne nouvelle avec
les chaleurs qu'on connaît instrument
c'est plus agréable plus agréable de se
balader dans la rue sans masque mais par
ailleurs ce n'était pas en extérieur que
se passait les contaminations c'est
souvent dans des lieux clos dans des
cercles familiaux et le masque avait été
imposée en extérieur pour accoutumer les
gens à le porter dans les lieux clos
donc enlever le port du masque en
extérieur c'est une mesure c'est une
bonne nouvelle ça montre que nous
sortons progressivement de cette
troisième vague mais ce n'était pas là
que se passaient l'essentiel des
contaminations
simard chose ça peut avoir un impact
dans l'opinion cet allégement des
mesures sanitaires
je pense que celle espérée parce que
pour le coup c'était pas attendu et
encore une fois dans l'opinion je pense
pas qu'ils aient eu une aspiration à une
anticipation des mesures au contraire
d'ailleurs je pense qu'il y avait une
responsabilisation était fait dans
l'opinion assez marquée avec les étapes
à suivre dont on s'attendait on avait
tous en tête ces différentes étapes là
donc je pense que c'est effectivement un
effet d'annoncé alors on peut se réjouir
parce qu'effectivement c'est positif
et puis c'est plus agréable mais je vois
plutôt ça comme effectivement peut-être
un pas de côté politique est habile de
communication politique à quelques jours
d'une échéance électorale et à la veille
de la coupure estivale
justement on va en parler de ces
élections en virginie martin est ce que
vous pensez qu'il ya une dimension
électoraliste dans l'allègement de ses
mesures sanitaires a finalement à
quelques jours du premier tour des
élections régionales
oui en tout cas ici bien non justement
puisque la populaire maintenant c'est
intéressant parce que là c'est un peu en
bouclier qu'on espère tous et toutes
celles qui étaient qui montrent qu'il
n'y avait par hasard un retour de bâton
ce serait très grave et la politiquement
ce serait évidemment très agréable donc
il ne faudrait pas que de cet
allaitement finalement au sorte quelque
chose de beaucoup plus durs derrière
qu'il a évidemment lors les régionales
serait pas chier bien entendu mais
c'était plus dur pour l'année prochaine
aussi
on regarde la présidentielle sur la
capacité ou non tant gouvernement à
gérer correctement une telle crise
alors on va parler de ces élections
régionales et départementales puisque le
premier tour a lieu dimanche prochain il
pourrait y avoir une forte abstention on
va avoir quelques éléments d analyse
avec ce sujet d'autres états et de
gaspard flamands lors des dernières
élections régionales et départementales
en 2015 50 % des électeurs ne s'étaient
pas rendus aux urnes
cette année il pourrait être encore plus
nombreux 60% d'après un sondage ifop
soit près de 20 millions d'électeurs
première raison le paradoxe français
alors que les français ont une meilleure
image
les locaux que leur les élus nationaux
alors qu'ils ont le sentiment qu'au
niveau local il peut voir concrètement
les résultats des politiques publiques
municipales départementales et même
régional et bien les scrutins locaux
mobilise beaucoup moins que les scrutins
nationaux et notamment les scrutins
régionaux et départementaux
difficile de décentraliser le scrutin
pourtant les compétences des régions et
des départements ont été élargies en
2015 mais pour les électeurs c'est le
grand flou surtout à l approche de la
présidentielle de 2000 22
on a un débat qui est saturé par des
enjeux nationaux et une campagne qui se
fait surtout sur la sécurité je suis pas
sûr que les électeurs apprécient ce
décalage est cette année comme pour les
municipales en 2020 la pandémie s'invite
dans les urnes ce soit pour certains le
risque d'aller voter ou pour d'autres
l'idée qu'on sort de d'une période très
contraignante et il s'agit d'en profiter
pour les loisirs
ce livre est un devoir
alors les 20 et 27 juin chaque électeur
aura la possibilité de recevoir les
procurations de deux personnes au lieu
d'une habituellement à stewart show je
m'adresse aux spécialistes de l'opinion
est ce que dimanche prochain on va
encore vers une majorité
d'abstentionnistes force est de
constater que oui en tout cas si on en
croit les différentes intentions de vote
réalisé par par les confrères et nous
mêmes on avoisinerait effectivement les
60% selon selon l'ifop alors on est dans
un contexte par rapport à 2015 qui est
quand même très différent déjà dans une
temporalité différente au sort d'une
crise sanitaire qui a ébranlé le pays en
2015 rappelez vous c'était en décembre
donc quelques semaines un mois après les
attentats donc on est quand même dans
des temporalités qui sont très
différentes mais je pense qu'il ya deux
registres qui sont associés à analyser
dans l'abstention le premier c'est un
registre structurel il y avait un cycle
d'abstention en france qui s'explique
par une déconnexion aujourd'hui perçue
par les français entre leurs
préoccupations et la manière dont s'est
traduit en l'offre politique donc
aujourd'hui ya pas d intérêt pour la
chose publique et politique
les résultats d'une grande enquête que
l'on a mené
viavoice libération il n'y a pas un
désintérêt un désamour pour la politique
qui a une déploration finalement de la
manière dont elle se fait et elle
s'organise aujourd'hui et le deuxième la
deuxième chose pour revenir sur ce que
disait monsieur cautrès très justement
le côté de territorialiser finalement de
cette élection et peu perçue par les
français
les régions sont très très grande on a
des disparités en interne des régions
donc c'est compliqué de retrouver voyez
ce caractère proximité qui fait
effectivement parfois acte de
mobilisation dans dans l'opinion donc
ces deux éléments je pense convergent
vers une abstention qui s'annonce assez
importante
janyk a démis on sort d'une crise est ce
que ces élections finalement sont une
véritable préoccupation pour les
français préoccupation non en tant que
tel est-ce que ça suscite de l'intérêt
on vient de on vient d'en parler en tout
cas en creux avec le taux
d'abstentionnisme attendu je ne vais pas
revenir sur ce que sur ce que sur ce que
vous avez dit sur ce qu on dit en
général maintenant je pense qu'il ne
faut tout de même pas comment dire
banalisée l'intérêt que les français
pourraient avoir vis-à-vis de ces
élections parce que même si elles sont
compliquées
même si c'est évidemment pas la
présidentielle ou des législatives
on a vu par exemple pour les européennes
y avait eu une mobilisation certaine et
puis une verdict des urnes
extrêmement important pour autant pour
les partis qui sont sorties en tête que
pour ceux qui sont restés à la traîne et
que même si encore une fois tout ce qui
a été dit sur le flou qui entoure les
départements et les régions dans
l'esprit de nos concitoyens et est
réelle je pense que contre comment dire
contrairement à ce qui pouvait se passer
lors des scrutins précédents
eh bien les régions sont beaucoup plus
incarné pour ceux qui votent dans leur
propre région que par exemple les
départements qu' il y a plusieurs il ya
plusieurs années donc
même si un fort taux d'abstention pour
toutes les raisons que nous disons je
pense que les régionales resteront
plutôt deviennent deviennent de plus en
plus rendez vous électoral extrêmement
important pour les français est ce qu'il
faut en tirer un test national
notamment parce qu'à la présidentielle
dans quelques mois ce qui aussi fait
l'originalité de ces régionales je crois
que c'est la première fois que ce
scrutin est aussi proche de la
présidentielle on en parlera peut-être
tout à l'heure j'en sais rien je ne suis
pas sûr que l'ensemble des résultats qui
pourraient tomber au premier et au
second tour vont être pertinent pour ce
qui pourrait se passer en 2022 à la
présidentielle et aux législatives
certains deux autres en revanche
pourrait donner des signaux notamment
sur le rassemblement national et sur les
verts aussi les écologistes on parlera
de l'analyse nationale et politique de
ce scrutin clos ridel je voudrais
revenir sur leurs sur le rapport entre
les français et ses régions ses
départements qui ont des compétences sur
importants comme les transports le
développement économique pour les
régions encore le social pour le
département est ce que les français sont
au fait de toutes ces compétences qui se
joue avec ces élections je n'en suis pas
sûr et justement les régions des
compétences très importantes notamment
pour le transport vous l'avez rappelé la
formation professionnelle le
développement économique mais on ne
parle pas de ça il ya une prof un
profond décalage entre ce qu'est la
compétence des régions et ce sur quoi se
fait le débat on le voit en île de
france mais aussi en paca mais aussi en
auvergne rhône-alpes
j'aurais envie de dire un peu partout on
on va parler les candidats qui font
campagne sur les enjeux de sécurité ou
d'immigration alors même que la région
ne peut strictement rien en matière de
sécurité ou de police donc il ya ce
décalage peut-être qui est source de
confusion dans la tête des gens mais
autrement sur le sujet de l'abstention à
mon avis il ne tient pas qu'à ça et je
me suis d'accord avec qui a été dit il
ya des raisons conjoncturelles et des
raisons structurelles les raisons
conjoncturelles c'est qu'on sort du coc
vide que les français je pense sont
lassés de la politique très très
profondément
ils s'intéressent davantage à l'euro à
la réouverture des terrasses et aux
vacances qui approchent que un scrutin
dont ils ne comprennent pas tous les les
tenants et les aboutissants et puis il
ya aussi des causes structurelles
puisque l'abstention augmente depuis 40
ans sur toutes les sûretés les scrutins
en france donc il faut se poser la
question de ce qui cause cette
désaffection profondes des français
vis-à-vis de la politique mais sur ses
causes structurelles virginie martin est
ce qu'on va encore s'inscrire dans cette
vague de défiance vis-à-vis des
responsables politiques avec ces
élections régionales oui bien sûr ça
sert conti évidemment l'abstention et
tous s'y construisent autour de cette
défiance voire cette défiance avec donc
on a beaucoup parlé aussi des affaires
dont du problème de la confiance
vraiment entre le top et le politique
mais aussi une défiance quant à la
capacité finalement dû politiques à
résoudre correctement les problèmes qui
nous préoccupent et qui préoccupent les
français et les françaises sont aussi
censés d'aveu d'échec comme si
un peu le politique était dépassée alors
par la mondialisation par de très
grandes entreprises par des chocs
finalement aussi par l'écologie qu'est
ce qu'on peut faire véritablement au
niveau des nations comme cela donc c'est
un peu leur puissance politique avec
beaucoup évidemment de changement
profond de changement paradigmatique on
pourrait dire et donc cette inefficacité
ressenti peut faire peur et ça s'est
fait comme ça même si à à l'abstention
ça fait partie d'eads et des causes de
l'abstention
sur les régions peut être un point qui
n'a pas été encore vraiment soulever
c'est aussi la personnalisation ou
l'absence de personnalisation des têtes
de liste et ça c'est important aussi
même ceux qui gèrent les régions je le
vois notamment on peut parler évidemment
de valérie pécresse en ile de france 2
de laurent wauquiez en région aura ou en
paca ono muselier certes ce sont des
noms que les gens connaissent ci ou là
mais ça manque quand même d'une
incarnation et d'une personnalisation on
sait on peut le regretter ou you no kill
grande personnalisation politique est
quand même aussi où les gens à se
projeter dans un scrutin là parfois on
sent très bien sur le terrain que les
ont finalement ne savent pas qu'ils sont
les patrons de régions où les patrons
les patrol de département et ça aussi
c'est un problème je n'ai pas aimé une
réaction à ce que 10 à virginie martin
et l'incarnation je suis d'accord avec à
peu près tout ce que vient de dire
virginie martin notamment sur le le le
le la perception qu'ont les français de
la capacité d'impuissance de la ou de
l'inefficacité en tout cas de l'action
publique bon ça c'est une chose en
revanche là où je ne suis pas d'accord
pardon virginie martin avec vous c'est
sur l'incarnation
je pense que la région et je le disais
tout à l'heure est un organisme en
devenir et on va être à la deuxième
élection sur la base de ces régions méga
région équipe type celle comme on dit
créé par françois hollande et au
contraire je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
plus de français qui connaissent le nom
du président de la présidente de région
parce que là celle que vient de citer à
west vient de citer virginie martin y en
a donné des bertrand est connu enfin bon
carole delga est connu et bien d'autres
combien de citoyens connaissent le nom d
vous le disiez virginie des présidents
de conseils départementaux beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup moins donc moi je
pense au regard de l'ajustement de la la
la mondialisation ni pour ni contre mais
en tout cas de l'évolution de l'économie
et peut-être des structures politiques à
venir je pense que la région est la
grande région sous réserve de certaines
améliorations dans le fonctionnement
probablement
je pense que d'abord elle est plus
adapté premièrement deux va prendre du
poids et 3 et elle est en train de le
devenir est de plus en plus incarné est
repéré par les français je voudrais
qu'on parle du climat de cette campagne
avec beaucoup de tension de polémiques
de violence je vais rappeler brièvement
les violences de ces derniers jours avec
notamment le président de la république
emmanuel macron qui a été giflée jean
luc mélenchon enfarinée tout comme
françois d'origine de rugy ancien
président l'assemblée nationale qui est
tête de liste de la majorité
présidentielle dans les pays de la loire
il a été en farine et par une femme
vendredi soir ce week-end également en
haute vienne un candidat a été victime
d'injures racistes et il a dû est bien
là décidé de retirer sa candidature et
et puis on en a beaucoup parlé ce
week-end toutes les invectives qu'a reçu
le ministre la justice eric
dupond-moretti de la part de ses
adversaires politiques
ce week-end dans son déplacement dans à
péronne dans la somme
on va arrêter on va avoir une réaction
en salle des conférences du sénat avec
steve jourdain à propos de ces jeux de
ces violences steve vous êtes avec la
sénatrice les républicains de paris
c'est une boulette péronier oui madame
vous l'espériez bonjour j - 4 avant le
premier tour des régionales on parle
beaucoup de violence dans notre société
cette violence vous l'avez ressenti à
l'occasion de cette campagne électorale
je les ai ressenti à l'occasion des
campagnes électorales je la ressens
depuis plusieurs années elle monte
incontestablement alors elle se
concentre au moment où il ya des
élections ce qui n'est de toute évidence
pas une bonne chose mais il ya
différentes formes de violence il ya
celle qui est sur le coup de la colère
un électeur qui n'est pas content qu'ils
refusent de vous serrer la main ce qui
pour moi est une forme de violence aussi
parce qu'on peut serez la main pour toi
même si on n'est pas d'accord sur les
idées et puis à l'afflux relance qui est
plus prémédité et qui intervient comme
la farine ajout l'enfermement au moment
où on sait qu'il ya des caméras et que
ça va pouvoir être repris par la presse
et par les réseaux sociaux qu'ils
allaient me gêne presque d'autant plus
pour vous les expliquer cette violence à
l'encontre des élus il ya différentes
manières de l'expliquer c'est très
compliqué en quelques secondes comme
cela mais je dirais que d'abord il ya
une volonté de
de d'une partie de la population à dire
je ne veux pas que vous représentiez et
par conséquent je vous le montre par des
gestes violents qui un agressent et
peuvent être dangereux et de dégrader la
fonction voilà tourne au ridicule ce qui
a plusieurs effets pervers dont
l'abstention dont une confiscation du
débat public mais qui est contesté de
dégrader l'autorité mais elle ne
concernait pas que les politiques
malheureusement elle concerne nos forces
de l'ordre elles concernent les pompiers
elle concerne parfois les personnes qui
prennent soin de notre santé
et ça ça me gêne beaucoup et l'autre
raison que je vois aussi c'est peut-être
une prééminence des extrêmes et dans un
et ça me fait penser que le débat n'est
pas apaisées aujourd'hui dans notre
société alors qu'ils devraient l'être
on est dans la campagne pour les
élections régionales on devrait parler
des compétences des régions
et certainement pas se battre autour des
politiques madame boulet ce péronier
l'actualité c'est aussi ces annonces de
jean castex avec la fin du port du
masque obligatoire à partir de demain la
fin du couvre feu à partir de dimanche
est ce que vous dites ou ça y est on y
est ouf ça y est on y est alors au sujet
du port du masque je me félicite de
cette décision que je viens d'apprendre
et qui intervient un jour il fait 35
degrés donc là on est tous soulagés de
savoir qu on n'aura plus à porter le
masque libres à certains qui sont le
plus dans la précaution est de continuer
à le porter en extérieur puisque vous le
dit à juste titre ce port du masque est
toujours été controversé moi j'ai bien
dans la commission denquête qu'ovide 19
et à l'époque déjà on disait est ce que
vraiment il faut le porter à l'extérieur
et à l'époque déjà c'est en septembre
dernier
ça n'avait pas été prouvée
scientifiquement je veux croire que
cette décision cela dit que je salue
parce qu'on en a tous vraiment assez et
puis voilà ça ça comment dirais-je à
perturbe les relations sociales on a
envie de retrouver les visages des gens
qu'on aime et des personnes qu'on
connaît moins alors pour les politiques
là il intéresse aussi peut-être vous en
tant qu elle a faim de trophées mais ces
décisions je veux bien croire ont été
prises en concertation avec la
communauté scientifique comme pendant
toute la crise j'espère le politique a
tranché non j'ai applaudi cette décision
dans un contexte où le virus circule
merci beaucoup c'est une boule espère
onu merci de venir aux questions de
public sénat
merci merci beaucoup steve chloride elle
jouerait qu'on revienne sur ce climat de
violence
est-ce que c'est propre à cette période
où au final ça a toujours été le cas et
finalement les réseaux sociaux les
vidéos qu'on voit rendre le côté un peu
plus viral de ces violences non je pense
que il ya un climat particulier de
violence très clairement qu'il y a plein
plein de choses l'action politique a
perdu de sa superbe
les réseaux sociaux et c'est démontrer
engendre une polarisation très forte de
la société et/ou un propos outranciers
sur les réseaux sociaux a plus de
chances d'être relayé qu'un propos
mesurés et on se retrouve avec ses
réseaux sociaux qui consomme 3 % de la
population mais qui influencent
largement par ailleurs le débat le débat
médiatique et qui prennent en otage en
réalité 60 70 % des français donc je ne
sais pas comment on en sort mais il faut
vraiment qu'on prenne conscience
peut-être que ce sont des minorités qui
prennent en otage le
le débat public et que ça a des
conséquences très concrètes sur la façon
dont on banalise par exemple des gestes
de violence envers le président de la
république
on a entendu plein de propos qui
regrettait que l'auteur de la baffe au
président et est jugé beaucoup plus vite
que l'auteur d'autres de violence congé
comme si le présent la réplique n'avait
aucune importance et qu'il fallait comme
ça le rendre équivalent toutes les
gestes que ce soit envers les
dépositaires de l'autorité ou les
personnes à six morceaux cette analyse à
sion de la violence est ce qu'on la
ressent dans l'opinion ou alors est ce
que c'est vraiment minoritaire alors
c'est où ils font ce qu'il faut rappeler
une chose c'est que l'opinion sera une
grande globalité majorité déplore ce
climat le volant cela donc il ya une
minorité qui se rend de plus en plus
visible qui se rend de plus en plus
active qui passe peut-être effectivement
de plus en plus à l'acte mais
fonctionnera grande majorité des cas les
français sont réticents un réfractaire à
cette idée à cette idée de violences par
contre là où est-ce que où les choses
sont sont réels il va falloir quand même
nous y attarder c'est qu'il ya un climat
de violence qui font qu'un moment donné
on banalise
effectivement ce genre d'agissements
c'est à dire que finalement à voir que
ce n'est plus très exceptionnel on en
parle peut être un petit peu moins et
d'une manière peut être un petit peu
moins avec un peu moins de deux draps de
drames voyez un peu moins de gravité
or ça je pense que c'est un c'était un
point réel réel problème et puis juste
pour terminer sur cette question de la
violence je pense qu'ils ce qui change
aujourd'hui c'est les lieux aujourd'hui
du conflit social je pense que là
effectivement l'institutionnalisation du
conflit ne se fait plus elle ne se fait
plus par les corps intermédiaires elle
ne se fait plus par le personnel
politique donc elle se fait parfois par
le citoyen dans un acte individuel
irréfléchie et qui va faire
effectivement qu'on va se retrouver avec
des minorités violente qui vont qui vont
passer à l'acte alors qu'elle ne faisait
pas auparavant et c'est lié avec cette
crise de la représentativité dont on
parle est au tout début de l'émission
virginie martin ces violences durant
cette campagne
c'est la suite logique des conflits
sociaux qu'on a connue durant ce
quinquennat avec la crise des juges
hawn également la crise des retraites
oui bien sûr ça peut tout à fait être
dans cette lignée mais peut-être plus
globale os qui vient d'être d'être qui
est cette polarisation en effet du débat
cette polarisation des idées par
définition cette polarité va engendrer
des toutes façons de la violence qu'elle
soit symbolique réel verbale c'est
évident par ailleurs il ya aussi un
autre point c'est que la fonction
politique est vu et ressenti par un
certain nombre de gens comme illégitime
et ça c'est très important si cette
illégitimité de la fonction finalement
est-ce que untel ou untel est légitime à
me représenter ça c'est un vrai problème
et c'est une vraie ligne
il ya aussi bien entendu cette capacité
qu'ont les réseaux sociaux à faire
caisse de résonance finalement sur des
événements qui serait peut-être passé un
peu inaperçu ou qui ferait dans le fait
divers de la presse quotidienne
régionale
et bien tout d'un coup ça monte en
épingle parce que via les réseaux
sociaux
évidemment ça arrive jusqu'aux grandes
scènes nationales et donc sa fille aussi
une caisse de résonance donc là aussi il
faut un peu raison garder et ne pas non
plus rajouter si je puis dire du drame
au drame ce soir c'est aussi un peu le
propos du précédent interlocuteur et
puis celle qu'on vit aussi on a dit à
tous les individus et c'est tant mieux
qu'on démocratie bas tout bois compte
eh bien parfois il y en a aussi qui ne
passe plus en effet par des coalitions
par des groupes organisés et que leur
voix ils ont aussi envie de la faire
entendre
quels que soient les moyens pour le
meilleur et pour le pire
et oui les partis politiques n'ont
peut-être plus la même force pour
rassembler justement je voudrais qu'on
évoque l'enjeu les enjeux politiques de
ces élections notamment du côté du
rassemblement national ce serait
peut-être la première fois que le
rassemblement national arriverait à
conquérir une région janica les miss à
partir de cette crispation du débat il
ya un vrai enjeu politique sur ce point
oui on parlait tout à l'heure de la
nationalisation des
des élections régionales on parle
effectivement de certains thèmes qui
étaient régionaliser alors qu'ils le
sont peut par exemple la sécurité même
si dans les transports publics et les
lycées c'est et de responsabilité des
régions et l'aspect test l'aspect
verdict des régionales par rapport à un
test en tant que test national je pense
encore une fois qu'il ne faut pas le
tirer par tous les bouts en revanche
vous avez raison un des éléments qui
donnerait une tonalité est insensé qui
préfigurerait peut-être de ce qui
pourrait se passer en 2022 et de ce qui
se passe depuis plusieurs années c'est
la conquête par le rassemblement
national d'une voire deux voire plus
mais en tout cas d'une ou deux régions
parce que aujourd'hui bien sûr le
rassemblement national n'en a aucune et
c'est d'autant plus importante pardon
c'est important de par la dynamique
intrinsèque que ça représenterait pour
le rassemblement national
c'est important aussi parce que on parle
de marine le pen face à emmanuel macron
donc c'est quand même une fragilité ce
serait une fragilité
si l'une des régions passées au front
national semble mains sales une
fragilisation de du discours et de la
position d' emmanuel macron et bien sûr
l'autre élément puisque rassemble
nationale me semble-t-il est à droite et
l'extrême droite ça irait bien sûr
participerait bien sûr et on voit
notamment en paca à l'implosion de
l'autre grand parti de droite que sont
les républicains donc oui une conquête
du rassemblement ciel d'une région
serait triplement pertinentes au plan
national pluriel c'est le duel entre
emmanuel macron et marine le pen à la
présidentielle qui en train de se jouer
avec ces élections mais sans doute que
ce duel annoncé influence beaucoup les
élections régionales puisque dès lors
qu'on a nationalisé ce scrutin il est
naturel que les prochaines grosses
échéances électorales
l'influencé c'est dommage parce que
justement c'est un scrutin qui doit
permettre de donner de la respiration
qu'il crée aussi des contre-pouvoirs on
a créé des grandes régions dans l'esprit
de pouvoir avoir des alternances au sein
d'un même mandat et c'est ce qui
aujourd'hui est tout largement je pense
la vie politique française c'est que on
manque de contre pouvoir et le pouvoir
est concentré dans les mains d'une seule
personne qui concentre à la fois toutes
les colères et toutes les satisfactions
s'il y en a
et ça n'est pas ça n'est pas soutenable
donc il faut trouver un moyen de
relocaliser ces élections je ne sais pas
si un décalage dans le temps suffira ou
s'il faut carrément remettre en cause la
façon dont on a grandi ces régions qui
ne colle plus aujourd'hui avec la réelle
des réalités culturelles et
anthropologiques que séculaire en tout
cas dans l'esprit des français est ce
que ces élections locales ont une vraie
dimension nationale voire chaud oui je
pense que oui alors je voulais juste
revenir sur le cas du rasoir national
puisque il ya une dynamique oui par
contre dit l'ami ne veut pas dire
forcément progression si on regarde les
intentions de vote aujourd'hui qui sont
réalisés il y a six régions où elles
sont en tête 5 où ils sont en seconde
position
par contre si on regarde le score qu'ils
ont fait par rapport en 2015 il n'y a
que trois régions sur lequel ils sont à
plus de 30% alors qu'ils en avaient six
en 2015 donc ça veut bien dire qu'il ya
une dynamique qui réel qui est certaine
notamment nouvelle aquitaine avec une
liste qui fait force politique alors que
c'est une région qui est plutôt
imperméable assez assez force du rapport
national mais ya pas forcément une
progression en termes de lanternes de
voix au niveau national il était à peu
près à 28 % en 2015 ils seront peut-être
à peu près à ce niveau là il y aura pas
forcément une forte progression pour
l'assemblée nationale ce qu'ils fassent
jouer c'est ce que disait madame et demi
c'est la victoire
effectivement peut-être en région paca
alors ils sont le mieux placées avec
thierry mariani on se rappelle qu'en
2015 le front républicain avait fait que
christian estrosi avait pu empêcher la
victoire et puis ensuite il y aura les
hôtes france évidemment avec un duel
très attendu avec savez avec xavier
bertrand est ce que oui ou non il y aura
un basculement un basculement danser
dans ces régions là mais voilà dynamique
ne veut pas forcément dire progression
donc il faut aussi avoir en tête ces
éléments purement électoraux bourgogne
franche comté bourgogne en suivra avec
attention le dimanche soir sur l'antenne
de public sénat merci beaucoup à tous
les cas tu d'avoir été mes invités sur
ce plateau c'est la fin de ce débat il
est 14h30 dans 30 minutes
c'est le début des questions d'actualité
au gouvernement on va suivre cette
séance de questions d'actualité avec
toute notre équipe steve jourdain en
selle des conférences du sénat pour les
réactions des ministres et des sénateurs
jean massiet le streamer politique qui
commente la séance sur sa plateforme
twitch avec sa communauté
et puis quand un calmer en tribunes de
presse de l'hémicycle quentin quelles
vont être les sujets forts de cette
séance de questions d'actualité
et bien alex les lr avait prévu une
question sur la pertinence d'un
couvre-feu à 23 heures ils maintiennent
cette question ils vont justement
s'interroger sur les tergiversations du
gouvernement des derniers jours
dernières semaines comme notamment
rappelez-vous avec la dérogation permise
en demi finale de roland garros les
sénateurs ps veulent poser deux
questions sur l'hôpital public notamment
sur les oubliés du ségur de la santé
enfin les communistes veulent relancer
le débat autour de la levée des brevets
des vaccins envoyait beaucoup de sujets
sanitaires encore aujourd'hui d'autres
sujets d'actualité 1,5 me de cette
semaine comme et bien une question sur
le projet de loi climat dont on sait que
le sénat vient de commencer cette
semaine l'examen en séance les
écologistes veulent quant à eux
interrogé notamment sur les inquiétudes
autour d'un nucléaire en chine et plus
généralement sur les dangers autour de
la technologie du nucléaire la droite
l'a posé des questions sur les finances
publiques l'immigration encore par coup
sûr un dernier mot pour mentionner la
question des centristes sur les erreurs
dans la distribution de la propagande
électorale cela concernerait des
endroits où l'ajustement le gouvernement
est bien à sous traiter cette mission de
la distribution de la propagande c'est
donc à suivre en direct à partir de 15h
alex bien sûr merci beaucoup
quentin pour toutes ces précisions on va
parler maintenant du projet loi
antiterroriste qui est examinée en ce
moment au sénat en commission on va
d'abord voir quelles sont les mesures
principales de ce texte défendu par le
gouvernement
on voit ça avec toutes les explications
de guillaume bertrand le projet de loi
terrorisme et renseignements a été
adopté sans surprise à l'assemblée
nationale il ya deux semaines il est
désormais examiné par le sénat le texte
prévoit notamment pour certains détenus
condamnés pour terrorisme
ayant purgé leur peine l'interdiction de
sortir d'un périmètre donné pendant
trois mois avec obligation de pointage
et la surveillance des données de
connexion internet et son extension aux
url supposé donner des informations plus
complètes dès sa présentation devant la
chambre haute les sénateurs ont tenu à
apporter des précisions techniques par
exemple sur la durée maximale de ces
mesures de surveillance renouvelables
dans le texte initial pendant deux ans
ou encore sur le traitement des données
internet de là où se niche le risque
c'est dans l'incertitude juridique et on
a vu qu'il y avait encore un certain
nombre de dispositions notamment par
exemple quand la délégation générale à
l'armement de venir travailler sur les
données de connexion et d'infos que ce
soit dans les services est pas
l'extérieur pour pas que la donne et se
promènent et qu'il y ait un risque de
confidentialité de son côté l'exécutif
un objectif assumé
le texte doit passer l'épreuve du
conseil constitutionnel
comme vous l'imaginez cette nouvelle
proposition tire toutes les conséquences
de la décision du conseil
constitutionnel du chef tout dernier le
7 août 2020 les sages avaient déclaré
contraire à la constitution plusieurs
articles du projet de loi et pour le
gouvernement il ya urgence
les dispositifs de surveillance en cours
expire le 1er août prochain une nouvelle
censure du texte créerait donc un vide
juridique dans le suivi des sortants de
prison et pour parler de ce projet de
loi de lutte contre le terrorisme
j'accueille sur ce plateau marc philippe
daubresse sénateurs les républicains et
rapporteur de ce projet de loi au sénat
bonjour bonjour
j'accueille également sofitel polluants
sénatrice écologiste
on va d'abord commencer sur l'objectif
de ce projet de loi marc philippe
daubresse est ce que c'est une nouvelle
étape plus efficace dans la lutte contre
le terrorisme
à écouter ça fait déjà un certain temps
qu'on parle de ce projet de loi le sénat
qui a toujours eu une position d'
équilibre entre respect des libertés
d'un côté et autorités de l'autre côté à
travailler sur ce qu'on appelle la loi
s'il tente ou terroristes on a décider
de la tester pendant plusieurs années
entre 2017 et 2020 et nous nous avons
proposé a déjà huit mois qu'on l'a
pérennise
on nous a répondu un problème et il ya
la pandémie faut attendre
donc là on a perdu huit mois les mesures
qui sont proposés pour la plupart
reprennent d'ailleurs des amendements
que j'avais fait mais ce projet doit
pose d'autres questions qui sont
justement la conservation des données
comme l'a dit ma collègue et la
compatibilité entre ce que veut faire le
gouvernement
on en parlait tel conseil
constitutionnel et c'est là où nous les
sénateurs qui sommes
j'ai été député donc je sais de quoi je
parle un peu de tout
l'outil est juridiquement que les
députés nous disons attention casse cou
on va parler de cette dimension du
renseignement et de conservation des
données dans ce projet loi sofitel et
polluant est ce que vous avez le
sentiment qu'on va franchir un pas qu'on
va gagner en efficacité dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme avec ces mesures
écoutez je crois que surtout on poursuit
sur cette même pente qui est extrêmement
dangereuse qui est d'être de mettre de
plus en plus en de pérenniser de plus en
plus de dispositions qui étaient jusqu'à
présent dans le cadre de l'urgence et
que cela mettrait profondément en cause
l' équilibre entre les libertés
publiques et le risque terroriste
le risque terroriste il existe personne
ne le nie mais on ne peut pas non plus
considérer qu'il n'y en aura jamais
aucun et il faut bien qu'on ait en tête
que à chaque fois que nous pérennisons
des mesures de type état d'urgence dans
le droit commun nous restreignons les
libertés publiques souvent depuis
plusieurs années maintenant nous
enlevons des prérogatives au jus nous
les confions aux préfets et c'est
extrêmement dangereux
cette pente donc moi c'est cela qui
m'inquiète aujourd'hui la question
évidemment des données personnelles des
données médicales se pose de manière
extrêmement précise et pointue mais je
crois qu'au delà c'est cette pente que
nous devons examiner cette pente
dangereuse qui n'est ce qui nous éloigne
finalement de la démocratie des libertés
publiques qui fondent notre république
au nom d'une gestion du risque qui de
toute manière ne pourra jamais être 0
marc philippe daubresse vous les avez
évalué ces mesures depuis des années ces
mesures qui viennent de l'état d'urgence
dans un contexte
crise terroristes est-ce que sur le
terrain concrètement elles ont été
efficaces quand on les a exprimés pour
les mettre dans l'oise comment j'ai fait
de rapport là dessus et je suis allé
voir sur le terrain
pardon les préfets pour voir comment ça
se passait dans les zones les plus
sensibles notamment les zones
frontalières
donc j'ai franchement ces mesures ont
été expérimentées et le conseil
constitutionnel qui n'est pas tendre
avec nous le conseil constitutionnel a
considéré que telle qu'elle était
proportionné telle qu'elle était elle
était efficace tôt que l'un pour moi la
chose et et trancher maintenant et je
dis à ma collègue quand même l'année
dernière et environ 80 personnes qui ont
purgé leur peine des terroristes qui ont
été condamnés qui sont sortis de prison
cette année à peu près autant l'année
prochaine à peu près autant vous êtes
donc à peu près 250 personnes qui ont
été condamnés pour des faits graves de
terrorisme ou d'apologie du terrorisme
qui sortent de prison et kinés et qui
ayant purgé leur peine en droit français
il n'y a plus aucune mesure raison pour
laquelle nous avons proposé ce qu'on
appelle une mesure de sûreté qui est pas
une double peine mais qui nous permet de
faire une surveillance mais sous
contrôle judiciaire alors que le
gouvernement lui veut faire une
surveillance à partir de l'autorité
administrative donc la police ou les
services secrets ce qui n'est pas tout à
fait pareil parce que l'autorité
judiciaire et +40 d'indépendance
concrètement ce que propose la
commission des lois du sénat et que
cette mesure de sûreté
c'est une surveillance pendant combien
d'années nous nous autres et la sortie
de prison nous opposons à la proposition
du gouvernement de doubler d'un an les
mesures de contrôle et de surveillance
qu'on appelle les me casse pour
l'instant elles sont prévues jusqu'à un
an au maximum et là ils veulent les
mettre pour deux ans de ces mesures de
surveillance qui permettent de da sign à
résidence de dande interdire d'aller
dans telle département de pointer tous
les matins tu sais nous nous proposons
de supprimer cette mesure parce qu'elle
va être censurée par le conseil
constitutionnel et de faire une mesure
de sûreté d'ensemblier c'est à dire
qu'il traite le problème de la
réinsertion de la déradicalisation t en
même temps qui permet de surveiller des
personnes qui peuvent reprendre contact
avec des milieux terroristes puisque
parquet national anti terroriste et sim
à peu près à 15 à 20% les individus
extrêmement dangereux qui vont sortir de
prison
c'est-à-dire 20% de 250 ça fait c'est
quand même 50 personnes dans la nature
donc il faut quand même qu'on prenne des
mesures donc nous les prenons mais
plutôt en utilisant la voie judiciaire
que la voie administrative
donc cette mesure de sûreté sous
contrôle judiciaire combien de temps
elle peut durer 5 ans 10 ans alors ça
dépend de la peine qui a été prononcée
avant la plupart du temps ce sera trois
ans à des stades ça dépend des plaines
qui ont été prononcées si vous voulez
c'est proportionnée comme on dit en
droit constitutionnel et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous pensons qu'elle va
passer le cap du conseil constitutionnel
sofitel et polluant est ce qu'on n'est
pas un peu dans la double peine quand on
surveille une personne qui est sorti de
prison à purger leur peine en droit
français mais je sais mais les médaillés
seront à dire ça je vous le dire je pose
la question en tout cas est ce qu
riddick mans vous avez vous avez pas
attention mais en tout cas voilà qu'est
ce que vous pensez de cette idée de
surveiller d'assigner à résidence une
personne qui a déjà purgé sa peine en
prison
écoutez c'est effectivement toute la
question de l'état de droit
un moment donné il faut qu'on soit
extrêmement vigilant parce que sinon on
entretient aussi un climat où beaucoup
de personnes ont le sentiment qu'on n'a
jamais payé alors même que dans l'autre
côté sur un certain nombre d'autres
sujets comme notamment les violences
faites aux femmes
alors là il n'y a pas de difficulté à
récidiver à aller et on l'a vu de
manière absolument terrible ces
dernières semaines à les tuer sans sa
compagne ou son ex compagne donc je
pense qu'il faut être extrêmement
attentif je fais confiance aux
rapporteurs
comme souvent à la majorité sénatoriale
par rapport aux mesures les plus
liberticides pour essayer de les
encadrer et je pense qu'effectivement ce
que monsieur daubresse ici exposé et
moins beaucoup moins inquiétant que ce
que le gouvernement propose dans sa
course poursuite avec avec le
rassemblement national pour celui qui
aura la meilleure la meilleure des pires
idées pour la démocratie
cependant je pense vraiment qu'on doit
que chaque citoyen doit s'interroger sur
la situation dans laquelle ou non et
comment
on est en bien en équilibre démocratie
et efficacité après moi je m'interroge
toujours et surtout au lendemain de la
réécriture du fameux article 24 qui
était censé être passé le fils du
conseil quand sujet qui finalement ne
l'a pas fait qu'est ce qu'il a dit
drissi nationale
je les réécrit l'article 24 en tant que
j'assume l'article 24 tout ce que j'ai
dit et a passé le filtre du conseil
constitutionnel mais c'est le mot
policiers en opération qui a été censuré
par le conseil
or c'est le mot qui restait de la phrase
de monsieur darmana donc il a censuré
plutôt monsieur darmana le conseil
constitutionnel c'est le moc policiers
en opération qui n'était pas clair de
son point de vue est donc là avec cette
version réécrite du projet de loi
antiterroriste réécrite par la
commission des lois du sénat selon vous
ça peut passer le filtre du congrès nous
répondons complètement aux exigences on
a déjà fait une proposition de loi nous
sénateurs et nos collègues députés qui a
été censuré par le conseil
constitutionnel
l'année dernière mais qui nous a pas
interdit d'en faire une autre qui nous a
dit dans quel cas de fallait le faire et
ce que nous proposons qui a été
d'ailleurs votée en proposition de loi
il ya trois semaines par le sénat répond
complètement aux exigences du conseil
constitutionnel
donc je suis assez confiant là dessus
est ce que le gouvernement est dans la
surenchère dans une course poursuite à
une réponse pénale plus forte visage et
je vais vous dire notamment dans cette
course avec l'eau des plantes le des
sujets que vous traitez canton les
terroristes sur l'agresseur d'un du
terrorisme moi j'ai été maire pendant 29
ans que témoin ça arrive à l'ancien
monde ça existe et j'ai été maire
pendant 29 ans je suis allé annoncer aux
parents d'un jeune de 27 ans qui venait
d'être assassiné au bataclan que je
connaissais les deux parents je
connaissais le jeune aussie ctg c'était
un joueur de tennis mme et bien je vais
vous dire que ces personnes qui sont des
bons citoyens qui n'ont jamais posé de
problème ne comprendrait pas que nous ne
prenons pas des mesures pour éviter que
ça recommence vous avez vu le match de
foot hier vous avez vu cette l aile de
deltaplane qui arrive sur le style fils
de greenpeace bon j'ai rien contre
rennes puis somme mais je veux dire si
ç'avait été un drone avec des explosifs
avec un terroriste qui manipule le drone
puisqu'il puisque l' aile de deltaplane
arrive à passer les obstacles
vous auriez pu avoir donc il faut
prendre des mesures de précaution et de
prévention
s'agit pas d'être ultra sécuritaire
c'est parce que je propose puisque je
propose de faire des choses sous
contrôle de l'autorité judiciaire
mais il s'agit d'être prudente prudent
et préventif
j'aimerais qu'on parle de l'autre volet
de ce projet de loi qui concerne le
renseignement et qui prévoit des mesures
pour mieux détecter les terroristes
notamment sur le net avec la technique
des algorithmes on va écouter le
ministre l'intérieur gérald darmanin sur
ce point il faut savoir que lorsque
quelqu'un tape cinq ou six fois une
recherche de vidéos de décapitation par
exemple de dèche sur internet les
services de renseignements ne peuvent
pas le savoir et sucettes personnes
demain nous pourrons connaître cette
information
la dgsi demandera au ministre de
l'intérieur au premier ministre et à la
commission nationale des techniques de
renseignement qui est une autorité
administrative indépendante qui suit
déjà les écoutes téléphoniques
la possibilité de lever l'anonymat de la
personne qui fait ses recherches afin de
pouvoir si le menace est grave et avérée
de suivre et éventuellement intervenir
sofitel et polluant est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec le fait d'ouvrir un peu
plus les données de connexion des
français pour lutter contre le
terrorisme de les ouvrir aux services de
renseignements eh bien non parce que on
rentre là encore une fois dans une
contradiction majeure entre les libertés
publiques et la liberté individuelle de
d'opinion après je note que comme
d'habitude c'est toujours les mêmes
exemples qu'on donne évidemment
évidemment il faut mettre tous les
moyens nécessaires je pense qu'il faut
notamment renforcer les moyens humains
dans les services de renseignement c'est
quand même une priorité pour mieux y
compris traité ce qui arrive à la
plateforme pharos on a vu quand même
dans notre histoire récente certain
nombre de données qui était remonté à la
plateforme pharos et qui n'a qui n'ont
pas été suffisamment suivi bon mais moi
je constate aussi qu'il faut peut-être
davantage mettre de moyen sur notamment
les groupes d'extrême droite qui sont
une véritable menace pour notre
république aujourd'hui donc il faudrait
arrêter de prendre toujours des exemples
qui vise une forme de terrorisme car
aujourd'hui dans notre pays la violence
monte et la radicalité de l'extrême
droite est extrêmement présente aussi je
ne nie pas évidemment bien entendu le
terrorisme il
mist qui existe et qu'il faut surveiller
mais je pense que il faut avoir vraiment
une extrêmement attentifs être
extrêmement attentif à la mesure des
choses pour ne pas rentrer dans une
société où nous sommes tous surveillés
pour nos opinions et pour des délits
d'opinion mais cela nécessite encore une
fois plutôt que des textes et des effets
d'annoncé des moyens humains pour les
services de renseignements marc philippe
daubresse avec le volet de
renseignements de ce texte est ce qu'on
va être de plus en plus surveillées de
liberté sont en danger
écoutez on n'est pas avec big brother on
n'est pas en angleterre avec des caméras
partout on n'est pas dans le bureau des
légendes parce que les gens regardent
des séries et puis se dit ça se passe
comme ça dans la réalité c'est pas tout
à fait ça on est encadrée par des lois
alors je suis assez surpris que nos
collègues du groupe écologie soit six
pros liberté pour ce qui concerne
l'espèce humaine mais tellement
coercitives pour protéger la planète
en restreignant d'état de liberté de
l'espèce humaine faut protéger toutes
les espèces mais en premier lieu
l'espèce humaine on va parler là là ça
maintenant je voulais l'amener en cours
ou non nous sommes encadrés pourquoi
parce que nous avons la cour de justice
européenne qui vient de faire un arrêt
qui date d'octobre 2020 qui dit très
précisément ce qu'on peut faire ou ne
pas faire en matière de données
nous par exemple les sénateurs nous
avons dit ok pour continuer avec les
algorithmes parce qu'on a une
expérimentation et on a les comptes
rendus de cette expérimentation
on n'a pas dit d'accord pour ce qu'on
appelle les données url c'est à dire les
données de l'ordinateur
parce que nous n'avons pas aujourd'hui
et le rapport du gouvernement mais ne
nous est toujours pas arrivée sur la
question de cette expérimentation donc
on a dit on attend là dessus non sur les
données mais l'air est nous dit nous
nous la meilleure garantie qu'on puisse
donner de protection des libertés c'est
que nous allons respecter strictement
l'arrêt de la cour de justice européenne
c'est l'article 4 du projet de loi qui
fait que nous ne pouvons voir d'ailleurs
nous ne pouvons pas aller au-delà de ce
que veut faire le gouvernement parce que
le gouvernement s'ils voulaient aller
plus loin et si vous voulez par exemple
prétexté ça pour aller rechercher tous
les sms toutes les fadettes toutes les
données de n'importe quel des lacs on ne
peut plus le faire avec cet arrêt
européen qu'ils s'imposent en droit
français
que nous sommes dans un état de droit
comme vous disiez tout à l'heure ma
chère collègue et nous allons respecter
strictement cet état de droit dont il ya
quand même des garanties pour diriger
nos libertés tenez marc philippe
daubresse vous parliez d'environnement
vrai qu'on parle d'un autre projet de
loi importants qui a examiné en ce
moment au sénat le projet de loi climat
en selle des conférences retrouver steve
jourdain qui est avec l'une des
rapporteurs de ce projet de loi la
sénatrice les républicains martha dos
idrac oui martin décidera que bonjour
bonjour donc de ce texte climat dont
vous êtes rapporteur le sénat commençait
l'examen de ce texte depuis lundi ça va
durer longtemps il ya beaucoup beaucoup
d'articles 200 articles au total
aujourd'hui petit point d'étape
on en est où est ce que le sénat
vraiment relevé l'ambition de ce texte
du gouvernement comme vous l'aviez
promis
alors oui alors évidemment tant qu'un
texte n'a pas été totalement examiner et
totalement voter adopté on ne peut
préjuger de rien puisque l'arbre comme
vous l'avez rappelé nous avons commencé
son examen depuis lundi nous sommes déjà
on a bien avancé malgré tout puisque
nous sommes déjà au 13e article il nous
reste encore 1600 amendements examinés
donc c'est peut-être le sénat justement
relevé ses ambitions en matière de
transition écologique alors sur
différents sujets sur les différents
titres nous avons un certain nombre de
puisqu'on a réécrit de modifications
apportées à l'article 1 puisque
l'article a été réécrit on le savait
bien nous avons proposé quelque chose de
beaucoup plus complet d'une certaine
manière nous avons également introduit
les allégations de l'éco blanchiment que
nous avons interdit à travers
le fameux débat qu'on a eu autour de la
neutralité carbone
donc ce sont quand même des points qui
sont forts de mon point de vue mais nous
avons également aussi maintenu le stop
pub d'une certaine manière puisque vous
vous souvenez à l'article 9 il y avait
le souhait d'introduire 1,8 cuba les
sénateurs écologistes considèrent comme
des chiens de berger sur ce texte climat
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous dit
merci aux écologistes finalement il
vient de vous aiguiller sur le chemin de
la transition écologique vous pensez
vraiment quand on avait besoin des
écologistes pour nous aiguiller sur le
bon chemin comme vous dites non je ne
crois pas je crois que c'est un travail
collectif de la commission nous avons
tous énormément contribué à la enrichir
tous les tous les collègues en fait ont
déposé beaucoup d'amendements je vous
invite à regarder cela de près certains
qui ont fait débat d'autres qui ont fait
moins débat avec beaucoup plus de
consensus autour de leur adoption mais
globalement je pense qu'on peut dire que
je tout le monde à contribuer
effectivement à l'avancé de ce texte
le constat sur l'urgence d'agir pour le
climat est partagée à droite à gauche
peut-être ce qui vous distingue c'est
sur la méthode qu'est ce qui vous
distingue vous de vos collègues de
gauche là dessus alors ce qui nous
distingue
simplement c'est la méthode c'est qu'on
aime que les choses soient très
clairement dit que les choses soient
clarifiées et que l'on puisse
véritablement lorsqu on légifère avoir
un outil qui soit utilisable directement
et opérationnels directement dans
l'application de la loi je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui est important
parfois les symboles c'est bien et c'est
important de les porter mais je crois
que ce qui est encore plus important
c'est que l'on puisse donner 2
de l'opérationnel aux textes de lois et
de les appliquer 2 les appliques merci
beaucoup martha de civrac merci d'avancé
à mes questions
merci merci beaucoup steve soit chez
taleo l'an une réaction rapide et ce que
les écologistes et adressé un temps réel
sont vraiment sur la même longueur
d'onde sur ce projet de loi
je crois que ce que disait monsieur
daubresse est très intéressant il disait
oui vous oh oui vous vous voulez des
mesures pour la planète et contre les
hommes mais en fait nous nous avons une
vision du jeu et ses 200 rennes leur
place dans l'écosystème et c'est ce
respect mutuel qu'il faut travailler et
je pense que l'intégralité des
amendements du groupe écologiste qui
forment une vraie loi qui m'a
c'est-à-dire qui permet à la fois de
dire notre objectif moins 55% mais les
mesures concrètes en face pour y arriver
ou pourrait arriver ça permet
effectivement de répondre aux objectifs
et pas seulement d'être dans des effets
d'annoncé qui manquent leur
opérationnalité ma fille me reste la loi
101 elle est vraiment mieux que l'ess de
la majorité sont pas des moutons ils ont
pas besoin de chêne berger bon
deuxièmement vous prenez les vingt
dernières années la loi la plus
importante qui a bouleversé l'écologie
et qui a fait beaucoup pour
l'environnement c'est le grenelle de
l'environnement de jean louis borloo se
trouve que je suis un ami intime de jean
louis
donc je sais de quoi je parle et donc
moi je dis juste vous avez eu madame
voynet au gouvernement vous avez eu
madame duflot gouvernement qu'est-ce
qu'elle plus avancé nous nous sommes
très pragmatique
donc on se demande est peut-être moins
dogmatique nous sommes pragmatiques et
nous disons qu a quand même des
équilibres à trouver donc le
développement durable c'est
développement économique protection de
la biodiversité respect de la planète et
c'est aussi cohésion sociale il faut les
3 et c'est ce qu'on essaie de trouver
dans notre synthèse
on va passer à un autre sujet d'actu
donnez le moi mais je pense que la
petite différence c'est que les
écologistes n'ont jamais eu les manettes
totalement et je pense que ça va bientôt
arriver
on est ministre on aura l'occasion d'en
parler de cette loi climat dans les
prochains jours puisque hier encore deux
semaines de débats on va retrouver un
autre streamer politique jean masia qui
commande c'est ce qui va commenter cette
séance de questions d'actualité sur la
plateforme twitter avec sa communauté
jean quels sujets vous intéresser à les
membres de la communauté et bien écoute
alex le premier sujet évidemment c'est
cette annonce par jean castex de la fin
du masque obligatoire et la fin
prochaine du couvre-feu
ça amène d'autres questions de la part
des internautes notamment la suite du
calendrier
quand est ce qu'on va pouvoir par
exemple réouvrir les discothèques est ce
que les jours jeux vont bouger
plein de questions un peu précises où là
c'est peut-être l'occasion pour lise et
veyran obame jean castex lui même
d'apporter des précisions devant les
sénateurs cet après midi un autre sujet
alex qui intéresse beaucoup ma
communauté
c'est en cette ouverture de l'euro les
paris sportifs beaucoup de publicité sur
les applications de paris en ligne vise
particulièrement les jeunes
beaucoup d'articles sont sortis dans la
presse pour dénoncer les ravages chez
des jeunes précarisés de ses
applications de paris sportifs donc des
questions sur la régulation des paris en
ligne
ça fait aussi partie des sujets étaient
jeunes aimeraient bien voir aborder cet
après midi par les sénateurs lors de la
séance des questions
merci je suis à redon alex bien
continuer continue excuse moi j'avais un
sujet qui intéressait aussi ses lattes
et conjugue réalisation de l'allocation
adulte handicapé on se souvient que
c'était une pétition sur le site intrade
les cénacles pour mobiliser les jeunes
on a été voté par le sénat
est-ce que cet après midi les sénateurs
ils se font avoir un peu de réponses
vont vouloir continuer c'est ça aussi
c'est un sujet qu'on attend et le
dernier sujet ça on sait qu à cinq mois
devant l'assemblée nationale
là aussi le sujet pma dans la séance
voilà un peu les sujets qui ont cette
absurdité alex merci beaucoup
jean et on va en parler de cet
allègement des mesures sanitaires qui
vient d'être annoncée par le premier
ministre jean castex
on va retrouver steve jourdain en salle
des conférences du sénat avec alain
milon sénateur les républicains et vice
président de la commission des affaires
sociales oui
milon bonjour merci avec nous cet
allégement des mesures de restriction
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous
médecin je considère que le premier
ministre a cédé à la pression populaire
ce que je crains c'est que nous ayons
par la suite un rebond de l'épidémie
comme ça se passe actuellement
l'angleterre
il en irait salut maintenir ces
restrictions sanitaires selon je pense
qu'il aurait fallu et ma théorie pour
des responsables même le mans d'image
sans risque et en extérieur
je suis très favorable au port du masque
on peut le dire sans fois mille fois je
vous ai déjà dit le port du masque à
empêcher l'extension d'épidémique au
vide mais en même temps on n'a pas eu de
bronchiolite
on n'a pas eu de gastro entérite on n'a
pas eu de grippe donc le port du masque
est nécessaire là pour l'instant pour
les t bonds que les grippes tout ça ça
n'existe plus mais on voit bien en
angleterre que le variant qu'on appelle
maintenant delta s'étale un peu partout
sur le territoire d'angleterre et que le
premier mis cet objet de reprendre ddd
méthode de confinement le déconfinement
ça n'est pas le défoulement alain milon
vous est aussi président de la
commission spéciale de bioéthique le
texte de bioéthique sera examiné la
semaine prochaine dans l'hémicycle pour
la troisième fois en deux ans dans fait
ne saura pas vraiment examiner si j'ai
bien compris
mais la commission spéciale c'est nous
ensemble quand même à la troisième
lecture
la première lecture le sénat avait fait
un test particulièrement cohérent en
particulier dans tout ce qui concerne
d'éthique médicale
si on est quand même dans une loi de
bioéthique on n'est pas dans une loi des
tic sociétale et donc dans ce qui
concerne toute la recherche soit elle
cellules souches sur le génome sur la
génétique
le texte du sénat me satisfaisait bien
il était très avancé beaucoup plus
avancé d'ailleurs que le texte qui a été
voté par l'assemblée nationale
nous avons fait une deuxième lecture
puis nous avons fait une commission
mixte paritaire
pendant la commission mixte paritaire la
rapporteure
de l'assemblée nationale nous a quand
même dit à nous sénateurs que eux
c'était la majorité et que donc le texte
la majorité s'imposerait pas vis-à-vis
de ceux qui voudraient le changer un peu
et une fois cette cmp fait on revient
dans une troisième lecture ou une fois
encore on a le texte assemblée nationale
qui n'a rien à voir avec le texte voté
par le sénat en première lecture et qui
a toujours cette pma qui pour l'instant
occupe les esprits et je regrette la pma
c'est pas un texte de biotics un texte
d'éthique ni sociaux en deux mois un
million à ce que le premier parcours de
telma sera possible dès cette année
selon vous je pense que oui le sembler
national de vautrin si j'avais eu ce
texte au niveau sociétal je l'aurais
voté aussi merci beaucoup à la mi longs
merci d'avoir répondu à mes questions
merci merci beaucoup steve pour ses
réactions alors qu'on voit l'arrivée du
premier ministre jean castex à ces
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
jean castex qui n'est plus qu'à
contacter qui peut donc être présent
durant cette séance de questions
d'actualité au sénat il est également
accompagné du président du groupe
centriste au sénat hervé marseille
ma fille libre et je voudrais vous vous
entendre sur ce qu'a dit votre collègue
des républicains alain milon à propos de
l'allègement des mesures sanitaires de
la fin du couvre-feu plus tôt que prévu
et ce que emmanuel macron a cédé à la
pression populaire
aurier les élections bientôt c'est
peut-être ça mais la question c'est que
vous le voyez bien la vaccination
plafonne si on allait vers toujours plus
d'augmentation de la vaccination
et si on pouvait immunisés l'essentiel
de notre pays
bien sûr qu'il faut lever les mesures et
qui sont restrictives de liberté mais il
faut faire attention et vous voyez bien
ce qui se passe en grande-bretagne
actuellement et il ya un risque certain
que ça prenne au mois de septembre
donc il faut être il faut agir avec
discernement c'est pas pareil quand on
est en extérieur au milieu d'un espace
largement et ray vous quand on est dans
une salle confinée
mais il faut rester très prudent parce
que je le redis la question c'est la
vaccination est donc si j'ai un conseil
à donner c'est d'inciter plus que jamais
à la vaccination y compris les jeunes de
12 16 ans on va parler de l'actualité
internationale
pour finir à une réaction rapidement
c'est le foot et les polluants sur les
agissements de ces mesures
oui je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de
précipitations en réalité c'est la
pensant effectivement une fébrilité du
gouvernent
je pense qu'il faut continuer à aller au
pas à pas est très attentif à la
situation là on va donner le sentiment
que youppi la fête de la fête peut
reprendre et je crois que c'est
dangereux à un moment effectivement ou
le variant delta on pose beaucoup
d'interrogations donc moi je vraiment
j'adresse un message à tous et toutes
les gestes barrières les gestes
barrières les gestes barrière message de
prudence on va faire un dernier tour en
salle des conférences du sénat pour
évoquer l'actualité internationale et le
tour d'europe du président des états
unis joe biden
steve jourdain vous êtes avec le
sénateur joël guerriau oui bonjour
monsieur le sénateur semaine très
chargée sur le front international 1
pour joe biden et les états unis g7 en
angleterre sommet de l'otan rencontre
avec poutine
qu'est ce que ce retour de l'amérique va
changer pour nous européens
ce retour d'amérique à m'écouter
j'espère que l'un des sujets qui eux au
kilo tient à coeur ont été abordés avec
joe baden et je pense en particulier de
retrait progressif a lancé par le
président sur l'opération barkan puisque
c'est une opération d'une grande
importance pour nous tous
réunion tous teambuy d'aujourd'hui est
ce qu'il faudra attendre quelque chose
j'espère un peu d'accalmie parce que
vous savez combien les relations avec
les rues sont parfois un peu compliqué
aujourd'hui les russes se sont investis
de missions de paix en particulier je
pense ce sont entre l'agglo nice caen
sur la question du haut karabakh avec
l'arménie
je crois que là il ya aussi beaucoup de
sujets à traiter avec les russes d'où
l'importance d'avoir ce dialogue et
cette volonté de revenir à une situation
plus calme là on vient d'obtenir un
texte interdisant la promotion de
l'homosexualité auprès des mineurs
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire avec la
hongrie alors vous voyez combien
l'europe peut être compliqué puisque
c'est évidemment quelque chose qui peut
que nous scandaliser je dois beaucoup
mais parce que la séance vient de
commencer on dit dans l'oreillette la
séance vient de commencer peut-être
qu'on se retrouve juste après la séance
si vous voulez bien je suis en est mis
sur en hémicycle puisque la séance a
débuté sommes heureux de vous accueillir
après période d'interruption momentanée
que nous avons connue et aurez vous
recommenciez au sénat en quelque sorte
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues l'ordre du jour appelle
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
notre séance et retransmise en direct
sur public sénat et sur notre site
internet
chacun observera les valeurs qui sont
essentiels ici le respect des uns et des
autres et celui du temps de parole je
vais les réparant le président jean
claude requier pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
lesieu le président vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président après le grenelle et de
l'éducation le segura santé ou encore le
beau vaudra sécurité le président réduit
qui vient d'annoncer l'organisation à
rentrer états généraux de la justice
pour poursuivre le passage en revue des
politiques publiques
mangou se fait ici ces sept avant ce
talent le fossé entre le citoyen
institution judiciaire semble se creuser
pourtant la relation de confiance est
essentielle pour légitimer les décisions
qui sont rendus au nom du peuple
français je lis trial se récente on
puisse susciter l'incompréhension
l'émotion dans l'opinion mais dans un
état de droit la justice deux se
confondent paraît clair moral elle
applique la loi
dura lex sed lex et surtout pour nous
républicains de tous bords il n'ya pas
d'art choisir comme de collonges et
entre forces de l'ordre et magistrats
tous sont des sous sols des
fonctionnaires
oui il faut lui le service public et les
vendent nos valeurs et du week-end au
quotidien je tiens à les saluer et à les
remercier et non les opposer on doit
renforcer notre cohésion nationale
le sheikh prairies c'est ce dont notre
justice n'a pas besoin c'est le énième
consultation véhicules ensemble de
promesses et qui n'aboutiront pas
comment nous allons trop souvent connus
et qui décideront une nouvelle fois les
professionnels du droit comme les
citoyens pourront soit pas nous
défendons ici c'est plus accessible plus
simple et plus efficace
monsieur vries comment entendez vous
restaurer la confiance entre nos
concitoyens et notre justice
on vous répondra parole est à monsieur
le premier ministre monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
plan routier le 16 juillet 2021 bientôt
au nom devant vous à l'occasion de ma
déclaration de politique générale
permettez moi ça ne se fait pas de me
citer mais je vous déclare est la
justice l etat et les tasses et la
justice l'état depuis de nombreuses
années ne donne pas à la justice ses
moyens d'intervention
il en résulte que l'action des forces de
l'ordre se trouvent parfois sans suite
il en résulte des situation d'impunité
sont parfois ressentie de manière
inacceptable par nos concitoyens par les
élus des territoires et par les maires
au premier chef
j'entends accélérer la mise en oeuvre de
la loi de programmation et de réforme de
la justice par déploiement dès 2021 de
moyens nouveaux affectées au budget de
ce ministère en particulier rhin pour
rendre plus rapides et effectives la
réponse judiciaire améliorer la
politique des peines garantir la dignité
la réinsertion des prisonniers
moderniser le fonctionnement des
juridictions et bien mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
c'est ce que nous nous attachons à faire
les états généraux dont vous venez de
parler qui font l'objet de votre
question me permettez moi de vous
rappeler ce sera pas qu'on veut je
l'entend ici ou là une énième
manifestation qui pourrait décevoir les
professionnels puis je vous rappeler
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs qui l'ont été
demandé au président de la république
par les deux plus hauts magistrats de
france
la première faisant de la cour de
cassation et le procureur général près
ladite cour et le présent de la
république précisément parce que le
renforcement de l'autorité judiciaire et
des moyens consacrés au service public
de la justice sont au coeur de l'action
de ce gouvernement a décidé de faire
suite à cette demande
aussi ai je vous remercie de la
modération de vos propos qui ne me
surprend pas pour poser et objective et
le débat est rappelé que dans une
république démocratique comme la nôtre
la séparation des pouvoirs et le respect
de l'état de droit doit lier l'ensemble
de nos concitoyens
j'entends trop avec vous ici ou là y
compris et maintenant du champ politique
des propos je le dis tout à fait
inacceptables c'est dans la sérénité
qu'ensemble nous devons redonner à notre
justice les moyens qui lui ont été trop
longtemps compté nous avons eu la
semaine dernière plusieurs questions sur
ce sujet ici même au sénat madame la
sénatrice jourdain posé une question sur
les moyens un petit rappel un petit
rappel sur les dix dernières années sur
cinq ans entre 2007 et 2012
les pouvoirs publics ont donné 700
millions d'euros de plus à justice entre
2012 et 2017 840 millions d'euros de
plus sur cinq ans suivant sûr
quatre ans les quatre dernières années
depuis le début de ce quinquennat plus
1,4 milliard d'euros notamment permis
par les plus et pour cent qui ont été
votés en loi de finances pour 2021 et
nous allons poursuivre cet effort parce
que le pays a besoin d'une justice
efficiente
nous avons augmenté vous le savez de
manière tout à fait significative le
nombre de places en prison soit que les
programmes soit en cours soit que vimy
place cet été annoncé par mes soins et
par ceux du garde des sceaux
c'était en alsace il ya plusieurs
semaines nous faisons monsieur le
président de travailler ensemble
policiers et magistrats
il le saurai vous l'avez dit avoir
d'opposition il ne peut pas dans un état
démocratique dans un état de droit
démocratique y avoir d'opposition cette
question est centrale
sur ce terrain comme sur les autres
monsieur le président nous agissons
monsieur le président roch est présent
une remarque sur le choix du titre états
généraux de la justice
vandomme place en deux hommes auraient
fait trop chic trop bruyamment à 6e
tranche judiciaire états généraux par
contre c'est plus historique est plus
rassembleur et en conclusion je fais le
mien est proposée jérôme gavaudan qu'est
président du conseil national des
barreaux selon lesquelles les états
généraux de la justice doit pas devenir
un lieu de pugilat politique et
électoraliste
merci la parole est à notre collègue
daniel seulement pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité territoire vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
président chers collègues ma question
s'adressait à barda à madame barbara
pompili ministre de la transition
écologique et solidaire
lundi nous apprenions que le père de
taishan en chine connaissait une
augmentation de la concentration de
certains gaz rares dans le circuit
primaire de son réacteur numéro un
les autorités chinoises se veulent
rassurantes le taux de radiation se
situant dans les limites autorisées par
les normes chinoise limites qui sont
toutefois trois fois supérieur aux
normes françaises géométrie variable
pour éviter la
du réacteur madame la ministre compile y
tenait mardi matin les propos suivants
la radio il ne faut pas qu'on ait une
réflexion sur notre politique
énergétique
en partant d'un fait effectivement mais
les faits sont têtus
ou plutôt les défauts et incidents
s'accumulent depuis de nombreuses années
à flamanville ont été fouettés des
défaillances sur le béton les soudures
le pont polaire les valves construite à
l'envers l'epic a ajout encore les
accidents de travail et je ne fais pas
tout la liste
à cela s'ajoutent les dérives
financières plus de 20 milliards en 2020
soit six fois plus que le coût initial
prévu et un retard de livraison qui
approche les 10 ans en finlande
matériels et matériaux souffre de
défauts le retard de livraison est elle
plus de treize ans que les équipements
sont déjà trop vieux et doivent être
remplacés sur coup 7 milliards d'euros
dont près de 800 millions à charge de
l'état
en angleterre hinkley point tu connais
également retard et dérive des coûts la
cour des comptes par le sujet des ep
airs d'un échec opérationnel de dérive
des coûts et des délais considérables
madame la ministre le coût du mégawatt
heure nucléaire est largement
sous-estimée tout le monde le sait à
l'aune de ce que l'on peut qualifier de
fiasco industrielle où semble-t-il
pertinent de poursuivre cet engagement à
construire de nouveaux opm plutôt que de
mettre le cap de manière résolue vers la
sobriété les énergies renouvelables et
les technologies de stockage merci pour
vous répondre la parole et à madame
emmanuelle wargon ministre
est chargé du logement madame le
ministre avait la parole merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur salma je
voudrais d'abord vous rappeler que les
deux auteurs dont vous parlez les
opèrent de taishan 1 et 2 ont été
construits en coopération entre la chine
et les industriels français et qu'ils
sont exploités par une société chinoise
dont edf est un actionnaire minoritaire
et framatome un prestataire
l'exploitation et la sûreté relève donc
des autorités chinoises de leurs
responsabilités souveraine il ne
m'appartient pas de me substituer même
si bien sûr les contacts sont fréquents
vous posez au delà de la situation
chinoise la question du mix énergétique
en france
la réponse est simple notre politique
énergétique c'est un mixte avec
diversification et résilience il n'est
pas responsable de proposer aux français
une seule énergie quelles qu'elles
soient
comme solution au problème de transition
écologique dans notre pays tous les pays
du monde font en sorte de ne pas
dépendre d'une seule source d'énergie
pour la production d'électricité nous
avons besoin d'alternatives le nucléaire
comme toutes les énergies présente des
avantages il est décarbonée
mais aussi des inconvénients j'en
citerai deux la gestion des déchets à
long terme mais aussi peut-être de façon
moins connu la mobilisation des cours
d'eau pour les opérations de
refroidissement
c'est pour cela que nous avons
l'intention de baisser d'ici à 2035 la
part du nucléaire dans notre mix
électrique de 70 % à 50 % à ce jour le
seul projet de père que nous développons
en france et celui de flamanville vous
l'avez cité suite au rapport de la cour
des comptes l'état a demandé à edf de
mettre en oeuvre l'intégralité des
recommandations de l'audit conduit par
jean martin folz
la clé de la diversification de notre
mix reposera sur les renouvelables
nous passerons à 25% en 2020 à 40 % en
2030 en développant comme le prévoit la
programmation pluriannuelle de l'énergie
le solaire la méthanisation l'hydrogène
l'éolien terrestre et maritime
ces moyens nous permettront de produire
une électricité qui est aujourd'hui
l'une des plus décarbonés d'europe et
qui le restera
si seulement oui à voir le la vitrine
est fissurée et le coup sur lequel on
s'était basés est exponentielle on est
rendu à peu près à 120 euros du
mégawattheure pour le p r alors que les
appels d'offres pour l'éolien et le
solaire aujourd'hui son salon aux
alentours de 60 euros
cet artifice nous amène dans une impasse
on vous l'a assez dit et redit la parole
est maintenant notre collègue joël
guerriau pour le groupe les indépendants
elle oublie de territoire vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre le président de la
république a annoncé jeudi dernier la
fin de l'opération barkan depuis huit
ans 55 de nos soldats sont morts au
sahel nous rendent hommage à leur
mémoire ainsi qu'à l'engagement et au
courage de ceux qui poursuivent le
combat
à l'instant où je vous parle nous
déplorons la mort d'un soldat nigérien
et de deux blessés soldats français avec
le soutien de nos partenaires
la france se bat pour faire reculer le
terrorisme au sahel
la situation de la région se dégrade
néanmoins nous constatons que le nombre
de victimes d'actes acte terroriste
reste élevé au burkina faso au mali et
au niger des pays sont en train de
s'enfoncer dans l'instabilité politique
et les djihadistes poursuivre leurs
méfaits
la présence française est capitale pour
la sécurité du sahel le week-end dernier
à raid a permis de neutraliser capturer
des cadres de l'état islamique
notre armée continue de faire un travail
remarquable en 2023 après une sorte une
sortie progressive
vous annoncez une présence réduite avec
deux objectifs la formation des armées
locales et la conduite d'opérations
antiterroristes les parlementaires que
nous sommes qui ont toujours soutenu
l'action française au sahel auraient
souhaité être consulté sur le changement
majeur de stratégie que constitue cette
décision le retrait d'une partie de nos
forces s'inscrit-il dans un programme
stratégique concertée avec nos
partenaires partenaires africains
européens ou américains
sur quelle force pourront nous conter
pour lutter contre le terrorisme dans
une région qui est cinq fois plus grande
que ne l'était que ne l'est
l'afghanistan merci pour vos réponses
la parole est à madame la ministre
désarmement florence parly la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur le 10 juin vous l'avez rappelé
le président de la république a annoncé
la fin prochaine de l'opération barkan
et une transformation profonde de notre
engagement au sahel
alors je voudrais être très clair tout
d'abord en rappelant que nous sommes
présents au sahel
à la demande des états du g5 sel
deuxièmement que nous ne quitterons pas
la région et aux côtés de nos
partenaires sahélien mais aussi
européens et internationaux
nous poursuivrons notre engagement
contre le terrorisme parce que cela
reste notre priorité absolue
ce que nous voulons c'est changer de
logique et nous voulons aller vers
davantage de coopération avec les
sahéliens et leur transférer
progressivement la responsabilité des
opérations et avec nos partenaires
européens nous voulons aussi coopérer de
façon encore plus étroite pour les
soutenir par des formations et puis de
l'accompagnement opérationnel et enfin
nous souhaitons travailler avec les pays
du golfe de guinée qui sont exposés eux
aussi au risque d'extension de la menace
terroriste alors cette évolution va donc
nous conduire à réorganiser notre
dispositif de façon significative sur le
plan militaire
en nous appuyant notamment sur la force
takouba qui rassemble des détachements
de forces spéciales européennes en
soutien aux forces locales les modalités
et le calendrier de cette transformation
de notre engagement seront précisées
ultérieurement et je répond directement
à votre question monsieur le sénateur
nous allons d'abord consulter nos
partenaires puisque nous considérons que
ce sont eux qui sont sur le terrain avec
nous et je voudrais souligner devant
vous que tous nos interlocuteurs nous
ont confirmé leur souhait
2 poursuivre la lutte contre le
terrorisme nous aurons certainement
l'occasion d'y revenir avec vous mais je
voulais pour terminer vous dire que
cette coopération avec nos partenaires
c'est la clé du renforcement de notre
engagement collectif au sahel contre le
terrorisme merci monsieur ou madame du
vistre j'entends et je comprends vos
propos et vous précisez vos souhaits
mais c'est soit nous aurions aimé
pouvoir en discuter avec l'ensemble des
parlementaires josé poser quelques
questions nos réalités il ya beaucoup
plus de questions qui me viendrait qui
sont plus techniques sur notre capacité
de soutenir la minus madame nord etc etc
mais ces questions mais partent mais mes
collègues aussi ont des tas de questions
à poser donc je crois qu'elle est
essentielle et vous connaissez sérieux
de la commission des affaires étrangères
et de la défense du sénat que nous
puissions débattre sein d'une commission
avant de lire dans la presse les
intentions du gouvernement
merci donner la parole au président
roger karoutchi pour le groupe l'est
républicain
le premier ministre au delà du sahel la
haute assemblée serait très intéressé
par votre conception détermination à
lutter contre le djihadisme le
terrorisme islamiste
partout dans le monde parce que depuis
des années les gouvernements successifs
on dirait la haute assemblée que lutter
partout dans le monde
c'était la garantie de l'intégrité du
territoire français des français en
général
quel est votre détermination à lutter
partout dans le monde contre le
djihadisme on vous répondra par les
touristes de l'europe des affaires
étrangères monsieur le drian
monsieur le président karoutchi vous
avez raison de rappeler l'ampleur de la
menace et la nécessité d'une vigilance
extrême est de considérer que la lutte
contre le terrorisme une priorité
absolue on le voit bien se répandre
il n'y a pas uniquement que le sel il y
a depuis les jours derniers des
événements autour du lac tchad avec la
montée en puissance 10 soit des boko
haram
il ya la montée en puissance des shebab
dans le nord - zambie qu il y a le
risque de résurgence de dèche et en
syrie et en irak
il y a les risques liés à la situation
en afghanistan parmi d'autres face à
cela la réponse doit être globale c'est
à dire que elle doit être international
et globale en intégrant les éléments de
renseignement et nous avons au niveau
national et au niveau de la coopération
internationale depuis quelques années
singulièrement récemment renforcé nos
capacités nos moyens de collaboration
cette action signifie aussi
l'intervention armée
quand c'est nécessaire nous le faisons
nous le faisons au sahel
madame les années 20 le confirmer cette
orientation contre-terroristes de la
nouvelle inflexion de notre organisation
au sahel
faisons aussi toujours en syrie par
l'intervention de nos forces
basé en irak en jordanie pardon nous le
faisons aussi par les nations unies
puisqu'en ce moment même net en train de
se définir la stratégie antiterroriste
qui devrait réunir l'ensemble des actes
des pâtes des états membres des nations
unies sur la base de drones d'éléments
juridiques et de nécessité de sanctions
qu'il faudra mettre en place à partir de
listes nous le faisons en luttant contre
le financement gens pris l'initiative de
ceux de cette coalition que l'on appelle
le no money for terreur avec les
australiens il ya quelques mois et qui a
permis une résolution conseil de
sécurité en mettant des normes et des
sanctions à l'égard de toute complicité
sur le financement du terrorisme
nous le faisons aussi en luttant contre
la diffusion du terrorisme en ligne en
particulier depuis les événements de
christchurch et vous savez que a été
prise une initiative avec la première
ministre de nouvelle zélande d'une
coalition qui s'appelle l'appel de
crouch âgées qui a permis des avancées
significatives tout cela c'est une
action globale qui est régulièrement
révisés au niveau national dans les
conseils de défense que tient le premier
le président de la république monsieur
karoutchi chez le ministre la grande
absente de votre réponse c'est l'europe
alors en réalité les actes djihadistes
multiplient vous l'avez dit niger mali
burkina mozambique tanzanie irak syrie
un peu partout dans le monde et d'un
autre côté la turquie n'hésite pas à
dire qu'elle utilise des mercenaires
djihadistes syriens contre l'arménie
contre les kurdes en afghanistan en
libye et nos amis arméniens nos amis
kurdes
nos amis libyens auprès de qui nous
intervenons pour que la démocratie soit
rétabli se disent où est l'europe où est
la france
bien sûr nous protestons bien sûr nous
nous indignons mais ça ne suffit pas
pour préserver la liberté de ces peuples
menacés
lorsque l'europe lorsque la france ne
défendent pas suffisamment avec fermeté
ces valeurs démocratiques
lorsque notre jeu diplomatique notamment
par rapport à la turquie
n'est pas c'est le moins que l'on puisse
dire ces derniers jours d'une netteté
absolue
nous remettons en cause nos propres
valeurs de liberté de démocratie et
j'espère que nous n'en paieront pas un
jour le prix
[Musique]
la parole
et à notre collègue pierre louault pour
le groupe de l'union centriste
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse au ministre de
l'intérieur lors des législatives
partielles la distribution de la
propagande électro électorale a été
catastrophique
dans les territoires où ils devaient
être effectués par la société adriq
fléau qui a remporté l'appel d'offres de
l'état sur 51 départements les 20 et 27
juin prochains au lieu des élections
départementales et régionales et on note
déjà des dysfonctionnements des envois
prématurés ou qu'ils n'arrivent pas pire
des défauts de distribution avec des
enveloppes jeté par paquet soit dans une
même boîte aux lettres et au pire dans
des poubelles
alors que l'abstention atteint des
niveaux record nous prenons le risque de
voir certains électeurs privée
d'informations essentielles pourquoi
avoir retiré une partie du marché à la
poste qui assure pourtant le service
public de distribution du courrier toute
l'année dans notre pays
el saad possède la dref cartographier de
tous les français parcourent chaque jour
notre territoire et connaît chaque boîte
aux lettres par ailleurs le traitement
différencié des élections
départementales et régionales est
inacceptable et donne l'impression qu'il
y aurait une petite et une grande
élection
pourquoi différenciait les délais de
remise de profession de foi entre
élections départementales et régionales
qui auront pourtant lieu à la même date
cette désorganisation pertubent les
perturbe les électeurs avec une
propagande refus soit trop tôt soit trop
tard ou non refus monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous nous garantir que l'ensemble
des lecteurs auront des informations
nécessaires pour aller voter les 20 et
27 juin prochains pour vous répondre la
parole et cas je suis les intérieurs
reçu darmana vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur depuis 2005 le parlement et le
gouvernement ont décidé qu'il s'agissait
de sociétés privées qui distribueraient
la propagande
électorale et les règles de la
concurrence notamment le code des
marchés publics que je ne vous apprends
pas oblige tout autorités publiques de
mettre en concurrence ce qui a été fait
l'année dernière
à chaque fois que des marchés arrivent à
échéance et vous avez raison deux
sociétés ont gagné beaucoup d'autres
candidates et la société la poste et la
société adrexo la société adrexo a
particulièrement mal distribué une
partie de la propagande électorale et je
me suis permis de faire adresser des
connaissances et notamment relevant de
la législative partielle et je m'en suis
expliqué avec à la fin de ce préfet et
les préfectures pardon et avec les
candidats pour apporter les excuses et
évidemment du gouvernement qui a délégué
cette distribution est convoqué la
responsabilité de l'avs
la société adrexo même si les cas que
vous évoquez notamment de plis retrouvé
dans les poubelles ont été heureusement
le cas que dans deux villes mais ces
deux villes de trop vous avez tout à
fait raison et je condamne bien
fortement cela et j'ai demandé au
secrétaire général de remettre en cause
de marchés publics à la fin de la
distribution de départementales et des
régionales vous aurez bien compris qu'il
était un peu tard pour les quelques
jours qui nous laisse qui ne laissait
jusqu'au premier et au second tour
pourrait effectivement bien rappeler à
chacun ses obligations mais je ne peux
pas me soustraire
vous l'aurez compris au code des marchés
publics chacun longtemps
troisièmement je constate qu'il ya
parfois une divergence d'appréciation
sur la distribution notamment en temps
au moment du premier et du second tour
le code électoral contrairement à ce que
je peux dire entendre n'a jamais prévu
un temps de distribution et oui il ya eu
des envois qui ont été faits trois
semaines avant le premier tour parce
qu'il vous a pas échappé que le
législateur a souhaité que le lait de
scrutin pour la première fois depuis les
années 80 sont tout le territoire
national se tienne en même temps dans
des conditions sanitaires dont chacun a
eu l'occasion ici de dépendre des
difficultés et il sent que le
gouvernement lorsqu'il a consulté les
maires l'a bien évoqué mais je crois
qu'une grande partie de rassembler comme
le sembler nationale a souhaité
maintenir ces élections à ces dates
ils tribus et le courrier est un métier
est seul
tant pis pour le rap seul en france la
poste fait distribuer du courrier il y à
des élections dans 10 mois et je crois
que chaque candidat chaque électeur
attend que la propagande soit bien
distribués et aussi donner l'apparence à
leur collègue laurence cohen pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologistes avaient la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre en octobre 2005 l'afrique du
sud et l'inde déposée auprès de l'om
c'est une demande de suspension des des
dispositions des accords sur la
propriété intellectuelle adpi concernant
toutes les technologies développées
contre lakovic 19 soutenu par une
centaine de pays par la majorité des
membres de l' oms appuyé récemment par
le président des états unis joe biden
cette demande est défendu par des
militants syndicaux politiques
associatifs notamment dans les pays
pauvres qui se mobilisent contre les
effets de la propriété intellectuelle
sur le droit à la santé et l'accès
effectif aux soins et aux produits
pharmaceutiques
après avoir refusé la levée des brevets
le président de la république a indiqué
mercredi dernier devant des
représentants d'associations et jeudi en
conférence de presse que la france
soutiendrait la demande de l'afrique du
sud est de l'inde mais des ambiguïtés
demeurent monsieur le ministre
alors qu'une réunion informelle doit
justement se tenir à l'om c'est pouvez
vous nous préciser la position de la
france sur ce sujet quelles sont les
modifications que le président de la
république souhaite apporter à la
demande de l'afrique du sud est de
l'inde je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole est aux ministres de
l'europe les affaires étrangères
monsieur madame madame la sénatrice
nous sommes tout à fait convaincu de la
nécessité de faire du vaccin un bien
public mondial
et cet objectif requiert un certain
nombre de conditions d'abord des
contributions financières
nous sommes au rendez vous des dons nous
le sommes aussi et nous l'avons démontré
encore par l'intervention du président
de la république lors de la réunion du g
7 ans
on rit britannique une tranche c'est pas
des mots 60 millions de dons se sont pas
des mots et je voudrais vous dire
monsieur le sénateur que revenant
d'afrique ayant constaté avec un certain
nombre de pays
la collaboration constante tout
constante de la france pour l'ensemble
des responsables africains ce ne sont
pas des mots peut-être pour vous n'est
pas pour eux je veux dire aussi à
l'égard de la sénatrice qui m'a
interrogé que concernant l'afrique du
sud et l'inde
nous sommes en discussion avec eux y
compris en afrique du sud pour élaborer
la mise en oeuvre de projets d'usinés de
vaccins en afrique et singulièrement en
afrique du sud et au sénégal
l'objectif c'est de faire en sorte que
tous les élément bloquant pour une
diffusion mondiale de l'ensemble des
vaccins et unis visiter mondial de
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens mondiaux
puis se faire le plus rapidement
possible les facteurs bloquants ce sont
d'abord les facteurs liés à
l'exportation
j'ai bien noté que jusqu'à présent les
états unis d'amérique tout en étant
favorable à la levée des brevets n'était
pas favorable à la levée des processus
d'exportation
il semble que cette donnée là sont en
train de changer depuis la réunion du
week-end dernier et c'est tant mieux
en ce qui concerne les brevets nous
avons toujours été favorables sur le
fait que la propriété intellectuelle ne
veux pas être un obstacle à la diffusion
des vaccins nous restons de cette
logique là et nous constatons que au
sein de l'om c est au sein de l' oms il
y a aujourd'hui les dispositifs
nécessaires pour permettre à ce qu'il
n'y ait pas de d'accaparement des
brevets par des entreprises de
production pharmaceutique
il s'agit simplement de mettre cela en
oeuvre l'union européenne vient de faire
une proposition en ce sens elle ne
souhaitons qu'elle soit mise en oeuvre
au sein de ces organismes avec je
l'espère le soutien des états unis
d'amérique
ils ne doivent pas se contenter
uniquement da déclaratoire mais aussi de
gros bonnets son action écoutez quelle
crédibilité accorder à vos propos comme
ceux d'ailleurs du président de la
république quant au niveau 2
l'europe est bien finalement les députés
européens de la république en marche
s'oppose à la levée des brevets quand
vous même au niveau de votre
gouvernement vous refuser d'utiliser les
pouvoirs de réquisition des usines qui
ont été conférées au premier ministre
par la loi sur l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
donc levé des brevets parce que les
brevets c'est un verrou pour une
production finalement qu'ils soient
mondiale vous nous dites de belles
paroles mais ça ne passe pas au niveau
des actes si vous soutenez la demande de
l'afrique du sud est de l'inde
il faut le prouver il faut le porter au
niveau du g7 il faut le porter de main
au niveau de l' omc et pas seulement
faisant des promesses mais en faisant
des actes aujourd'hui en fait il y à un
casino spéculatif qui tourne à plein
pour big pharma est en fête
eh bien vous êtes du côté de big pharma
vous n'êtes pas du côté des populations
les populations qui sont pauvres et qui
sont privés de vaccins donc on ne peut
pas venir à bout de la pandémie avec
cette politique il faut que vous
agissiez il faut vous prenez vos
responsabilités
nous attendons et l'afrique du sud et
l'inde attendent des actes et pas des
paroles paroles et ses canaux fois
collègue nicole du rotor pour le groupe
du rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant vous avez
la parole chaque le président madame la
ministre
en 2019 mon département de l'eure avait
été l'un des 13 départements pilotes
pour la première édition du service
national universel le et ses nus et en
corps aujourd'hui en phase
d'expérimentation et un bilan d'étape
paraît nécessaire avant que soit
envisagé sa généralisation
vous êtes sur le point de lancer les
séjours de cohésion pour la première
fois dans tous les départements du pays
du 21 juin au 2 juillet prochain l'un
des intérêts incontestable du sn eu et
qu'il constitue un rite de passage vers
la citoyenneté
à l'heure où les valeurs de notre
république sont parfois très mise à mal
par ailleurs il offre aux jeunes la
possibilité de découvrir un autre
territoire et terme et le brassage de
jeunes d'horizons
et deux milieux sociaux très différents
à ce titre lorsqu'elle fut auditionné
par le sénat le 4 mai dernier et manuel
perez la déléguée interministérielle à
la jeunesse a déclaré qu'il fallait
encore renforcer cette mixité sociale et
c'est essentiel enfin un tel dispositif
paraît d'autant plus opportun
aujourd'hui puisque la crise sanitaire à
fragiliser le marché du travail et
l'employabilité des jeunes
le fmi a par est comme un outil pour
créer un pont vers l'emploi
deux mille jeunes avaient participé à la
première édition en 2019 l'édition 2020
a été annulée à cause de la crise qu
vide
vous avez lancé en janvier dernier
l'édition 2021 avec un objectif
d'attirer 25000 jeunes
cet objectif at il été atteint par
ailleurs le gouvernement voudrait rendre
le saigner obligatoire pour huit cent
mille jeunes dès 2024
à ce titre entre le plf 2020 et 2021 les
budgets du et ses nuits à doubler
passant de 29,8 à 62,3 millions d'euros
comment ont été utilisés ces hausses de
crédits et quels sont les éléments qui
aujourd'hui nous paraît justifié la
généralisation du et ses nuages huit
cent mille jeunes je vous remercie pour
vous répondre
la parole est qu'à la secrétaire d'état
chargée de la jeunesse et de
l'engagement le char à l abri vous avez
la parole merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs madame la sénatrice nicole
duranton je tiens d'abord à vous
remercier pour votre question parce que
ça me permet de remercier évidemment
plus de 18000 jeunes volontaires 18
mille jeunes français qui viennent de
territoires différents qui ont des
parcours de vie différents de
territoires ruraux de territoire de
quartier politique de la ville ou encore
de zones péri urbaines qui vont partager
15 jours ensemble qu'un jour où ils vont
vivre d'abord des rituels républicains
qui vont commencer par une levée de
drapeau par se retrouver autour de la
marseillaise mais également de vivre des
moments de démocratie interne
ils vont apprendre de nouvelles choses
se repérer dans une forêt à voir et
acquérir les presses les gestes de
premiers secours mais également
apprendre à débattre et à renforcer la
cohésion nationale puisque cette
génération aujourd'hui et vous l'avez
dit madame la sénatrice a besoin de se
retrouver de se souder et de créer des
liens
madame la sénatrice c'était résilience
évidemment l'objectif premier du service
national universel sous l'autorité du
premier ministre nous sommes partis
renforcer cette mixité sociale
nous sommes allés par parti chercher ces
jeunes des quartiers politique de la
ville pour qu'ils croisent pour qu'il
passe du temps avec nos jeunesse rurale
parce que nous jeunesse elles sont
diverses
madame la sénatrice l'objectif du et ses
nus a créé une ambition une ambition
réelle parce que c'est une volonté
aujourd'hui portée est souhaitée par
l'ensemble de l'équipe gouvernementale
ces 143 site aujourd'hui en france tous
les départements de france auront un
site de séjour de cohésion d'ailleurs
dans leur madame la sénatrice
le site sera le campus de l'espace à
vernon qui accueillera ces jeunesse il
ya plus de filles que de garçons les
équilibres territoriaux sont plutôt
réussis un tiers un tiers un tiers est
en réalité madame la sénatrice je crois
que au delà de rassembler autour de ses
rituels républicain autour de nos
valeurs pour faire vivre et renforcer ce
sentiment d'appartenance général oui ce
moment de concentrer permettra aussi à
notre jeunesse d'avoir un parcours de
citoyenneté où ils vont rencontrer des
corps en uniforme qu'ils soient
volontaires sapeurs-pompiers et
policiers ou anciens de nos
de nos armées madame la sénatrice ce
temps collectif c'est un avis c'est un
investissement et le budget de 2010 neuf
puisque c'est le fond de votre question
est en réalité renforcer nous sommes
passés de 2000 à 20 mille jeunes
accueillis cette année avec un coût
unitaire qui baissent faut remercier la
parole est maintenant notre collègue
michel meunier pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicaine
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres hier les
soignantes et les soignants étaient dans
la rue pour réclamer des revalorisations
de salaires et l'augmentation des
effectifs
le collectif notre hôpital c'est vous a
dévoilé ses propositions pour remettre
l'hôpital public réellement au service
de la santé des françaises et des
français
voici ce qu'il rappelle l'accès égal aux
soins doit être assurée par le service
public il faut augmenter le nombre de
soignante et de soignants par patient
pour avoir du temps à leur consacrer
et redonner du sens à leur métier les
lits d'hôpitaux doivent y être répartis
en fonction des territoires et non en
fonction des critères budgétaires les
citoyennes et les citoyens définissent
la stratégie sanitaire et délibère sur
les moyens humains et financiers la
santé et la préoccupation majoritaire
majeur dans notre pays
les propositions du collectif sont
pleinement à la hauteur de cet enjeu
elle tourne la page des fermetures de
maternités des longs trajets en
ambulance pour pouvoir consulter des
spécialistes
elles font oublier l'extrême fragilité
du système hospitalier qui a dû répondre
tant bien que mal à la crise sanitaire
depuis 15 mois
nous socialistes apportons tout notre
soutien à cet appel et appuyons la
démarche du référendum d'initiative
partagée et je salue ici l'engagement de
notre collègue bernard jomier aux côtés
de ce collectif monsieur le ministre ma
question est simple
qu'attendez vous pour engager cette
refonte
du système de santé qui placerait enfin
l'humain au centre de l'hôpital public
pour vous répondre à faro le cas
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
président hamza messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice je suis
particulièrement heureux de vous
entendre
apportez votre soutien à l'hôpital
public
oui oui madame je voudrais rappeler
devant le sénat les chiffres de l'ondam
hospitalier c'est-à-dire les moyens
qu'on donne concrètement à
l'hospitalisation publique et privée
pendant les cinq années entre 2012 et
et je peux vous donner les chiffres
avant il était plus élevée 2012
en dames exécuté 2,6 2013 2,1 2014 1,7
2016 1,5 en 2020 en 2019 avant même pas
survenue de la crise sanitaire et se
sont élevés à plus de 2,6 en pourcentage
évidemment nous avons tout de suite tout
de suite madame tirer les conséquences
de la crise sanitaire
l'ondam hospitalier en 2020 a été de
plus 8,9 et en 2021 exercice en cours à
plus 10,2 ça madame ce sont des faits
alors on peut quand on est dans
l'opposition on a tous été un moment ou
un autre
dire que dire que les autres ne font pas
finalement ce qu'on n'a pas fait soi
même mais voyez ça madame ça ne marche
pas je vous le dis ça ne marche plus
ça ne marche plus nous avons nous avons
nous avons tiré les conséquences en
engageant le ségur sur le volet humain
un autre chiffre
pardonnez moi je ne veux pas en abuser
cette année et je le dis parce qu'elles
seront pourvus nous avons augmenté
nous avons augmenté de 5700 places
le nombre de places à l'ifsi de 5900 en
école de soignante parce que le ségur de
la santé auxquels faisaient fallu ions
va créer quinze mille places en plus
à l'hôpital tout ça encore ce sont des
faits et des réalités et je le rappelle
le faisant dans un cadre concerté le
sénat c'est bien que le fameux ségur et
je pourrais parler du vol
investissements mais vous m'interrogez à
bon droit sur le volet humain 13 ult
d'une négociation et d'un accord
majoritaire conclu avec les
organisations syndicales représentatives
de ce secteur
je le rappelle parce qu'au delà du fort
cette méthode ma part est extrêmement
importante je vous remercie
merci merci mon premier ministre de
votre réponse je ne pensais pas vous
fâcher mais sachez et vous le savez que
l'hôpital public est en danger et que
les chiffres que vous ne donnez ne sont
pas forcément la réponse nous attendons
la refonte du système sanitaire
la parole est maintenant au président
françois noël buffet
pour le groupe l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président merci à ma
question s'adresse à monsieur mise de
l'intérieur très récemment le président
de la république a annoncé qu'il
entendait renforcer les mesures de lutte
contre l'immigration clandestine et
notamment en augmentant le taux
d'exécution des obligations de quitter
le territoire national
le dernier à vis budgétaire du mois de
décembre dernier de la commission des
lois a observé depuis longtemps
d'ailleurs il a confirmé plus d'actes
mans la baisse et la faiblesse de
l'exécution des retours dans les pays
d'origine des personnes en situation
irrégulière sur notre territoire
la déclaration qui a été faite par
présent de la république est
naturellement très intéressante et
monsieur le ministre nous souhaiterions
savoir quelles seront concrètement les
mesures que vous allez préconisé pour
pouvoir remplir cet objectif
[Applaudissements]
la parole est au ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur gérald darmanin merci monsieur
le président monsieur le président
buffet le premier à première phase on
est évidemment d'éviter que des
étrangers au séjour irrégulier l'insight
en nationale c d empêcher de rentrer en
europe ce régulièrement et en france en
particulier depuis mon arrivée au
ministère de l'intérieur
à la demande du premier ministre et du
président de la république il ya
aujourd'hui à la frontière espagnole
cinq fois plus d'étrangers qui sont
arrêtés à vendresse le territoire
national parmi eux beaucoup d'enfants
vous savez notamment par les mineurs
dits isolé puisque nous sommes à quinze
mille 15 mille personnes ont été
empêchées dans un seul territoire
frontière espagnole et 20000 que ça
depuis le mois d'août
vingt mille da la frontière italienne
quatre fois plus deuxièmement il faut
éviter le détournement du droit d'asile
vous le savez bien puisque le grand
problème aujourd'hui c'est l'arrivée pas
la demande d'asile de gens qui n'ont pas
à demander l'asile
cent trente mille demandes d'asile en
2019 je retire l'année des pots vides
qui n'a pas grand chose à dire
évidemment il n'ya 20000 à 25000 avec la
cndr avec la cnda y compris donc les
refus de l'administration accès à cet
asile leur est effectivement doivent
repartir le territoire seuls trente
mille je lave ou bien volontiers repart
du territoire national nous devons
exécuter cela et comment par des laissez
passer consulaires et comment on les
obtient et bon expliquant qu on baissera
les visages je m'en occupe avec les
mises affaires étrangères aux pays qui
le font l'année 2010 est une année
bizarre monsieur le président vous en
conviendrez à cause du coc vie de la
fermeture des espaces aériens je
pourrais vous dire sans rire qu'on est à
74 % de moins évidemment d'immigration
irrégulière vous dirais que ce n'est pas
raisonnable
mais l'année 2019 c'était d'autant plus
part aux responsabilités lorsque prison
de bucca mis en place la politique des
visas réadmission ses 34% de plus de
visas en moins qui ont été données et
64% de laissez passer consulaires
notamment des pays du maghreb et des
pays africains qui ont été données nous
devons continuer cette politique et
parmi les devants du président de la
république où c'est effectivement de
dire au pays maintenant que la vie
reprend la vie normale reprend il n'y
aura plus de visas de la france s'il
n'ya plus laisser passer consulaire
monsieur le président buffet oui
monsieur le ministre
j'approuve ce que vous venez de dire
mais je regrette
au nom du groupe en 2015 et en 2017
notre groupe a fait des propositions
d'une quinzaine de propositions pour
renforcer les mesures de lutte contre
l'immigration clandestine
deux en particulier la première qui
était de considérer qu'un refus
définitif de demandes de statut de
réfugié je dis bien définitive à
l'obligation de quitter le territoire
national cela a été refusé
la deuxième c'était le fait que l'on met
dans la loi qu'on pouvait conditionner
l'obtention de visas à l'obtention de
laisser passer consulaire ça a été votée
ici ça a été refusé
on a on a demandé à avoir un débat
annuel au sein de cet hémicycle
vous l'avez je crois organisé une seule
fois si demain il aussi dès aujourd'hui
vous devez afficher une nouvelle
politique migratoire
c'est à dire une politique cohérente
immigration régulière ils migrent à ce
traitement l'immigration irrégulière et
naturellement traitement de la s'il
tient un statut particulier il est
urgent de l'organiser devant la
représentation nationale car nous avons
des propositions concrètes à vous faire
et ne pas être simplement sur les
regrets mais que les mesures que nous
proposons vous proposons de les inscrire
dans la loi et de les exécuter merci
merci
dix ans
[Applaudissements]
la parole était notre collègue joël
bigot pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicaine
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
de la transition écologique et solidaire
votre gouvernement est très bon en
formules grandiloquentes états généraux
de l'alimentation hier de la justice
aujourd'hui grand débat monde d'après
mme exoplanètes great games à un
problème une solution
la communication vendredi dernier le
rapporteur public du conseil d'état a
estimé insuffisantes les mesures pour
réduire nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre il rejoint en cela l'avis de bon
nombre d'instances cnt l'heure où le
haut conseil pour le climat qui vous
rappelle que la décennie en cours est
crucial pour réaliser des changements
structurels
malheureusement et malgré la bonne
volonté affichée par la ministre dans
nos débats
nous ne voyons rien de neuf à l'horizon
le gouvernement campe sur son texte de
loi issu de l'assemblée et la
multiplication des avis défavorables sur
les propositions des sénateurs en est
une illustration en séance elle vous
prête à enrichir votre texte au sénat de
dispositions rehaussant nos ambitions le
travail que nous allons effectuer
pendant les dix prochains jours
est-il condamné à disparaître lors de la
commission mixte paritaire
madame la ministre ma question est
simple après avoir redéfini à la baisse
notre trajectoire bas carbone et
considérant comme vous l'avez reconnu à
plusieurs reprises que ce projet de loi
ne suffira pas quand allez-vous proposer
au pays un vrai plan de décarbonation de
l'économie et un calendrier de réforme
conforme à nos engagements nationaux et
européens on vous répond ne pas en être
labellisé délégué
en charge du logement pardon merci
beaucoup monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur bigot ce gouvernement a
vraiment un objectif de décarbonation
avec un objectif de baisse de 40% de nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre entre
1990 et 2030 et une étude récente faite
par un organisme indépendant le boston
consulting group montre que si nous
appliquons la totalité des mesures qui
sont déjà décidées ainsi que les mesures
qui figurent dans la loi climat a minima
telle qu'elle a été votée à l'assemblée
nationale nous serons en capacité de
tenir cette trajectoire
nous ne parlons pas que de la loi climat
et j'aimerais citer le plan de relance
30 milliards d'euros d'investissements
dans la décarbonation de notre économie
à commencer par la rénovation des
bâtiments publics et des logements mais
aussi les énergies propres
en ce qui concerne la loi climat c'est
un texte ambitieux qui vise à faire
entrer l'écologie dans le quotidien avec
des mesures excluent également très
forte par exemple la lutte contre
l'artificialisation et l'étalement
urbain
l'interdiction la mise en location des
passoires thermiques la régulation de la
publicité la réduction des vols
domestiques ou les zones à faibles
émissions
la première mesure que nous pouvons
prendre et ça concerne tout cette
assemblée et donnait pas baissé
l'ambition de cette loi au fur et à
mesure de l'examen au sénat et j'en veux
pour preuve la suppression de l'article
7 qui a été votée dans cet hémicycle qui
supprime la réglementation sur les
vitrines lumineuse
j'en veux pour preuve les décisions que
vous vous apprêtez à prendre sur la le
refus de la généralisation de
l'alternative végétarienne dans les
cantines par exemple j'en veux pour
preuve la décision que vous apprêtez à
prendre sur le décalage des et des feux
de cinq ans si nous voulons tenir notre
trajectoire nous devons voter la loi qui
m'a avec l'ambition qui est la sienne ou
en l'améliorant et ensuite nous aurons
besoin de continuer à travailler à
l'échelle communautaire c'est
l'engagement que nous avons pris au
niveau de l'union européenne pour
réduire de 55 % nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et là aussi nous serons
au rendez vous
monsieur migaud oui si j'en juge madame
la ministre par les rédactions qui a
dans cette salle le constat que vous
énoncez n'est pas partagé par tous nos
jeux si je vous interpelle aujourd'hui
c'est que le compte n'y est pas comme
l'a noté la convention citoyenne pour le
climat je comprends donc pas d'âme le
ministre que pour vous il est important
de tendre un énième grenelle à nouveau
varennes avant d'être tancé par le
conseil d'état vous mettez la france en
état d'insécurité environnemental alors
que le quinquennat précédent nous avait
placé à la pointe du leadership
écologique
vous pouvez encore relevé l'ambition du
texte en matière de rénovation
énergétique des logements de transports
de transition agro écologiques en
suivant nos propositions faites en sorte
que le projet de loi climat ne soit pas
qu'une goutte d'eau comparée à l'océan
des besoins
merci la parole et à d'autres collègues
philippe houllier pour le groupe l'est
républicain
[Applaudissements]
le président mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues gouverner
c'est prévoir
cet adage que le gouvernement devrait
réciter sans cesse s'applique à toutes
les politiques publiques et notamment
dans le domaine médico-social
en france la situation des 7200 ehpad
est extrêmement préoccupante
déjà avant la crise du coc vide le
personnel souvent en sous effectifs
étaient en souffrance et beaucoup
d'établissements devait investir dans le
cadre des travaux d'humanisation et de
rénovation la crise sanitaire que nous
avons connue a très largement amplifié
cette situation de nombreuses
organisations sont nécessaires dans les
structures de plus à la suite de la
pandémie les préconisations formulées
par les ars impose la réalisation de
nombreux équipements des sas de
décontamination des accès dédié et des
unités autonomes qui représente des
coûts élevés et nécessitent des surfaces
de construction plus importante
parallèlement en même temps dans ce
contexte la mise en application du
décret écoénergie tertiaire au secteur
médico social va imposer des nouvelles
normes environnementales et donc de
nouveaux coûts d'investissement certes
nous ne remettons pas en cause la
pertinence des mesures liées au co vides
et des actions en faveur de la
rénovation énergétique
mais l'impact financier pour ces
structures et le calendrier imposé
semble intenable des enjeux budgétaires
sont prévus dans les mesures du ségur
immobilier mais seront elles suffisantes
au regard des enjeux imposer ma question
est simple
avez vous évalué pour prévoir les
besoins sur l'ensemble du territoire
national
quels sont ils et quels moyens quels z
sont proposés par l'état non répondent
la parole et au secrétaire d'état en
charge de l'enfance ou des sabines
monsieur le ministre
bayer appliqué merci monsieur le
président mesdames les cff
madame la sénatrice messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le
sénateurs ont mouillé vous l'avez vous
l'avez évoqué la crise sanitaire mis en
lumière les difficultés auxquelles les
métiers du soin dans leur ensemble ont
pu ont pu dans lequel ils ont pu faire
faire face déficit d'attractivité d'un
certain nombre de ces métiers tant du
point de vue des sani des soignants du
fait de l'heure de leur salaire que du
point de vue des résidents en raison de
la vétusté de certains établissements et
dans le même temps on le sait la
pression s'accentue vous connaissez les
chiffres d'ici dix ans plus de 2
millions de personnes supplémentaires
seront temps en perte d'autonomie dans
notre pays de 2 millions de personnes de
plus de 75 ans a une double réponse elle
pense d'un point de vue humain pour
travailler sur l'attractivité des
métiers
je ne reviendrai pas sur les différentes
mesures qui ont été prises à l'occasion
du ségur de la santé et puis il ya tout
le volet bâtiment terme investissements
sur lequel porte davantage ne votre
question et qui fait l'objet une
politique volontariste évidemment sous
l'autorité de brigitte bourguignon qui a
engagé ces deux ces deux chantiers
s'agissant de la partie investissement
sûr sur les établissements le premier
ministre lui même le 9 mars dernier a
ouvert un grand plan d' aides à
l'investissement dans les hépatites un
plan de 2,1 milliards d'euros sur cinq
ans et qui prévoit de mobiliser dès
cette année plus de 450 millions d'euros
qui se répartissent comme suit 330 qui
sont consacrés à la rénovation justement
à la reconstruction et à l'extension des
établissements et services
médico-sociaux une enveloppe de 125
millions d'euros est également prévu
pour les investissements vous avez
souvent davantage du quotidien dans
l'est dans les ehpad 20 millions d'euros
iront à destination des résidences
autonomie et enfin 5 millions d'euros
seront attribués pour des appels à
projets nationaux la cns à parallèle de
cela à d'ores et déjà dressé un cahier
des charges pour verser ces subventions
et nous incitons tous les établissements
à se saisir rapidement de cette
opportunité sans précédent pour
moderniser leurs établissements et ainsi
améliorer le quotidien des personnes
âgées mais également des professionnels
qui en prendre soin fqu
monsieur le ministre donc nous vous avez
donné les chiffres qui sont intégrés aux
ségur de la santé côté immobilier les
connaissons nous laisse à lyon mais je
ne suis pas certain aujourd'hui que dans
lorsqu on fait l'analyse des besoins
financiers selon son département nous
ayons réellement la capacité de tout
faire et donc c'est vraiment le débat
c'est à la fois les des impacts liés aux
communes mais également tous les décrets
qui nécessiterait à mon avis une
suspension un moratoire de façon à tout
intérêt parce que on demande à
l'ensemble des structures de mener
l'ensemble des investissements dans la
même période
vous l'avez évoqué des chiffres pour
2030 sont inquiétants on annonce un
nombre de personnes en perte d'autonomie
relativement élevé s'il n'ya pas
d'anticipation et bien nous aurons
difficulté 2030 c'est demain matin dans
le matière d'investissement c'est demain
matin donc gouverner c'est prévoir et
nous sommes notamment aussi toujours
dans la tente depuis des mois d'une
hypothétique grande loi sur l'autonomie
annoncée par lequel un pic depuis trois
ans cette fois nous l'attendons nous
avons par anticipation voter cinquième
branche de l'autonomie il ya quelques
quelques quelques semaines quelques mois
pardon et pour lequel est bien
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas les
contourner les gros enjeux voilà donc
gouverner c'est prévoir et j'espère
simplement qu'à travers ce que vous et
vous qui nous n'aurions pas un autre
adage en tête
gouverner c'est faire croire merci
beaucoup la parole est à d'autres
collègues stéphane de lui pour le groupe
de l'union centriste
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères
monsieur le ministre lors d'une crise
sanitaire il est crucial que les
enquêtes scientifiques complète et
transparente puisse être mené nos
concitoyens ont le droit de connaître
l'origine d'une pandémie qui a durement
impacté leur vie quotidienne et c'est un
doux euphémisme de le dire en janvier
dernier l'organisation mondiale de la
santé a mené l enquête en chine pour
comprendre comment le virus de lakovic
19 avaient été transmis à l'homme mais
il semblerait que l'om est ce n'est pas
pu travailler librement lors de ce
séjour de quatre semaines à roanne les
résultats des experts sur place étaient
semble-t-il surveiller de près
et même de très près leurs conclusions
devaient être approuvés par un groupe de
travail sous l'autorité directe du
gouvernement chinois
on le voit on le sent on le sait
l'information est contrôlée elle est
filtrée probablement censurait plusieurs
journalistes chinois ont d'ailleurs été
arrêtés lorsqu'ils ont eu
l'outrecuidance de sonner l'alarmé
à propos du virus or les citoyens
chinois et ceux du monde entier ont
droit à la vérité sur l'origine de cette
pandémie
ce problème de transparence est
d'ailleurs d'actualité puisque suite à
un incident technique survenu avant-hier
sur l'un des réacteurs nucléaires de la
centrale de taishan dans le sud ouest de
la chine
l'exploitant de la centrale s'est
contenté laconiquement de déclarer que
les indicateurs environnementaux étaient
normaux sans autre précision le
ministère chinois des affaires
étrangères n'étant guère plus loquace
sur le sujet et pourtant s'il ya bien
deux sujets qui mériteraient de
respecter une règle basique de
transparence internationale c'est bien
le sanitaire et c'est bien le nucléaire
un défaut d'information officiel du
gouvernement chinois
avez vous réussi par des canaux
parallèles monsieur le ministre à capter
d'autres informations sur ces deux
sujets cruciaux
pour vous répondre la parole est aux
ministres de l'europe des affaires
étrangères monsieur le sénateur d'amy
vous avez raison sur le constat
sanitaires nous avions pris une
initiative lors de l'assemblée mondiale
de la santé en mai 2001 je dis nous
c'est la france avec nos partenaires
européens et nous avons demandé à ce
moment là une évaluation impartiale
indépendante complète transparente sur
la manière dont s'était nouée le
processus de la pandémie et nous avions
demandé en même temps toujours à
l'organisation mondiale de la santé de
formuler des recommandations en vue
d'améliorer les capacités mondiales de
prévention et de riposte à la suite de
cette démarche qui n'avait pas été
simple de faire adopter par l'assemblée
mondiale de la santé pour des résistants
ce que vous imaginez il ya eu une
mission de l'om est-ce qui s'est rendu
en chine pour essayer d'identifier
l'origine de la copie de 19 et
comprendre les mécanismes de
transmission du virus c'est le rapport
de cette première mission a été remis il
ya quelques mois
c'est une étape importante pour mieux
comprendre les origines du virus pour
réduire le risque des événements
similaires pourraient engranger d'un à
l'avenir mais dans notre esprit ce n'est
qu'une première étape et donc nous
considérons que le travail scientifique
doit se poursuivre dans la plus grande
transparence et nous appelons l'ensemble
des états membres à commencer par la
chine à la collaboration la plus étroite
avec l'organisation mondiale de la santé
ce qui a été ré exprimé lors de la
dernière assemblée mondiale de la santé
qui s'est tenue il ya quelques jours il
faut la plus grande transparence et à
cet égard l'union européenne a pris
l'initiative lors de la présentation du
rapport
proposer des recommandations pour
aboutir à la plus grande clarté sur
l'origine du virus et sur sa
transmission à la population humaine
vous avez raison c'est un droit de des
concitoyens mondiaux d'avoir toute
l'information nécessaire et c'est une
nécessité pour pouvoir demain prévenir
de ces thés aux urgences sanitaires
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue fabia jeunes et pour le groupe
l'est républicain
merci merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le premier ministre
vous venez d'annoncer la levée anticipée
du couvre-feu et c'est là une décision
bienvenue au regard de la situation
sanitaire et des huit mois de limitation
de nos libertés qu'il représentait mais
tout de même monsieur le premier
ministre
ces derniers jours nous interroge sur
votre façon de gouverner le pays
tout d'abord vendredi soir tandis que
mes concitoyens de digoin en
saône-et-loire respectait
scrupuleusement le couvre-feu et
quittait la terrasse du dock 713
guinguette en bord de loire à 23h au
même moment les privilégiés des loges de
roland garros scandaient merci macro
merci macron en hommage à celui qui les
avait autorisés à ne pas respecter le
couvre feu
quelques instants plus tard des jeunes
se faisait chargé aux invalides pour non
respect du couvre feu sera en même temps
a été vécue comme une injustice devant
le fait du prince
selon que vous serez puissant ou
misérable et puis ce week-end le
week-end
et puis ce week-end nos concitoyens ont
vu en boucle les images de vos ministres
ils ont vu votre ministre délégué à
l'intérieur chanter en meeting sur une
estrade sans masque ils ont vu le
ministre de l'intérieur ministre des
cultes en appeler à satan contre ses
opposants politiques et le faire à
l'intérieur d'un espace clos à dijon
sans masque et c'était sans compter sans
votre ministre de la justice qui
malheureusement à court d'arguments
n'avait plus que ses postillons à offrir
contre celle son adversaire identitaire
le garde des sceaux le garde des sceaux
n'ayant pas jugé bon de garder son
masque tout cela en exact contradiction
avec la nécessité de conserver les
gestes barrières que vous avez rappelé
alors monsieur le premier ministre à
quatre jours des élections
départementales et régionales
après le baiser qui tue dans le sud et
le parachutage des ministres dans le
nord nos concitoyens s'interroge votre
gouvernement cherche t'il se faisant de
façon volontaire mais irresponsable a
suscité l'incompréhension et la colère
des français pour mieux la faire
exploser dans les urnes pour vous
répondre la parole et au ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur gérald hormones ah
[Applaudissements]
oui merci monsieur le président devant
une question aussi posé monsieur
sénateur je vais essayer d'être à votre
écoute on veut rassurant d'abord pour
dire que dans notre pays nous pouvons
nous réjouir que finalement dans cette
séance de questions il n'y a pas eu de
questions a mis la culture pour savoir
comment se passer du culturel parce
qu'ils sont soutenus par le gouvernement
il ya peu une question mise économies
parce qu'il n'y a pas un pays au monde
qui a soutenu les commerçants les
artisans des entreprises il a fallu une
question mise de la santé parce que je
n'avais vous dis monsieur le sénateur
pendant des mois et des mois et des mois
partout sur tous les plateaux sans doute
dans vos territoires ici même que jamais
nous retenions vacciner au mois de juin
nous l'avons dépassé
et qu'avez vous remarqué monsieur le
sénateur que dans ce pays alors que tout
autour
regardez la grande-bretagne regard des
pays qui nous entourent ils ont ce
reporter des élections ils ont surpris
des mesures de coercition
nous pouvons enfin retrouvé une vie à
peu près normale est en fait parce que
c'est à tort en écoutant votre question
je me dis que c'est la politique des
grincheux qui vous suffit vous ne pouvez
pas vous réjouir
vous ne pouvez pas vous réjouir que les
français sont manifestement heureux de
revivre et que oui les mesures prises en
place par le gouvernement sont des
bonnes mesures
vous parlez de roland garros mais
parlait hier soir du match de football
hier soir nous avons appliqué avec mons
études effectivement par l'appui ce
genre d'ânerie et moi je trouve que
votre attaque de la police et de l'armée
française
hier pour voir les invalides est
particulièrement déplacée et je suis
très fier du travail des policiers des
drames que vous auriez peut-être dû
davantage saluer et je veux vous dire
que nous avons pris réponse études et
quel que soit des classes sociales
puisque vous déposez ainsi vous trempez
ont sans doute un peu de groupes
politiques sans doute effectivement
l'accès à des règles sanitaires respecté
et respectable
alors monsieur le sénateur en vous
écoutant en vous écoutant cesser la
politique des grincheux et soyez heureux
d'être en france et pour une fois une
fois ça changera rien aux élections ni
départementale n'irai jamais prises en
ciel avouez que nous avons tenu la
baraque et français peuvent en des
siennes
la parole et le temps notre collègue
jean claude tissot pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicaine
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres cette question
s'adresse au ministre monsieur virant je
vais peut-être passer pour un grincheux
un nouveau monsieur le ministre
l'intérieur mais quand même nous sommes
à l'écouté du peuple et de la population
donc on se fait aussi quelquefois leur
porte voix
il ya maintenant un peu plus d'un an
vous annonciez un plan d'investissements
ambitieux monsieur le ministre pour
notamment revaloriser le salaire des
soignants c'est ce qui allait devenir le
ségur de la santé la principale mesure
de ségur a été une augmentation du
complément de traitement indiciaire
accordée aux agents des hôpitaux et pas
de public c'est là en effet un geste
important pour apporter une juste
reconnaissance à ces professions pour
connaissiez enfin comme essentielle mais
dans le même temps ce geste a été
ressenti comme une gifle par toutes
celles et ceux qu'on a appelés les
oubliés du ségur tous les personnels des
établissements sociaux et médico sociaux
publics autonomes qui exerce pourtant
les mêmes métiers avec les mêmes
diplômes et sous le même statut mais qui
ont été tenus à l'écart de ce processus
une des premières conséquences a été une
perte d'attractivité de certains métiers
mon collègue franck montaugé me disait
encore heroes soir avoir été interpellé
par des soignants du secteur privé de
l'accompagnement spécialisés qui lui a
quitté leur structure la boule au ventre
pour aller chercher quelques dizaines
d'euros supplémentaires dans le secteur
qui a bénéficié du ségur
après avoir bataillé de longs mois
certains de ces oublis ont enfin été
entendus à partir du 1er octobre
prochain ils bénéficieront de ce même
complément en avril dernier c'est de ma
collègue michel meunier qui déjà vous
interpeller sur les nouveaux oublier que
vous étiez en train de créer en
répondant au compte gouttes aux
légitimes demandes des différentes
professions de la chaîne du soin le plus
inquiétant est que vous persistez dans
cette politique de division qui a causé
tant de sentiments d'injustice et de
désorganisation dans ce secteur ainsi la
revalorisation consenti le 28 mai ne se
fera au final que pour l'établissement
et c'est là c'est grave
bénéficiant d'un bénir d'un financement
de l'assurance maladie laissant ainsi de
côté tous les personnels des
établissements relevant du financement
des conseils départementaux
c'est pourtant un solidarité nationale
qui doit jouer d'autant plus que les
inégalités entre départements peuvent
être grande
je suis élu du département de la loire
qui est l'un des deux seuls départements
de france avoir refusé de verser la
prime colline aux personnels de santé de
personnes au personnel de service de
soins et d'aidé à domicile pour les
prochaines étapes de ce nécessaire
chantier de revalorisation des
professions de santé et du social et
nous semble indispensable d'ouvrir la
table des négociations aux représentants
de toutes ces professions
ma question est donc simple monsieur le
ministre il tape assez pour un grincheux
vous avez vous enfin entendu les
professionnels du soin du social et du
médico-social qui manifestaient encore
hier et allez vous apporter une réponse
d'ensemble ces professions qui ont été
trop longtemps laissée pour compte je
vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole et ministre
mais merci merci monsieur le président
madame et sénatrices monsieur le
sénateur monsieur le sénateur je vais au
contraire moi prendre le parti de me
réjouir de tous les efforts qui ont été
faits depuis plusieurs mois à
l'attention des différents
professionnels que ça soit l'occasion
ça a commencé à le faire mais pour moi
devrait insister sur effectivement
l'effort financier notamment massif à
l'attention de ses de ces professionnels
de santé qui le méritaient dont je salue
une fois encore l'engagement qui a été
le leur cette année et demie passées
dans le cadre des accords du ségur vous
l'avez existe une augmentation de 180
euros net par mois qui avait été décidée
pour 1 25 million de professionnels des
établissements de santé et des ehpad ce
une augmentation qui est inédite qui est
méritée qui concerne également plus de
90 mille professionnels qui exercent
leurs fonctions auprès des personnes en
situation de handicap personnes âgées ou
en difficulté sociale a récemment
signature d'un accord de méthode relatif
à l'attribution d'un complément de
rémunération personnes seulement et
structures pour personnes handicapées
des services de soins à domicile
suite aux travaux et à l'excellent
travail de monsieur lafourcade qui a été
aux dires d'ailleurs de l'ensemble des
parties prenantes qui est qui étaient
aux négociations
cela a permis à ces organisations
syndicales représentatives justement et
aux fédérations d'employeurs de
s'entendre sur plusieurs points il a
tout d'abord été rappelé l'importance de
stabiliser les conditions de la
revalorisation pour préserver la
stabilité des effectifs favoriser la
mobilité des professionnels parce qu'il
est aussi cet aspect là qui est
important le gouvernement s'est engagé à
ce que le financement de la
revalorisation soit s'établit à compter
du 1er janvier 2022
dans le cas de la loi de financement la
sécurité sociale pour 2022 qui va qui
arrivera bientôt à la rentrée prochaine
devant votre vote rassembler les
organismes gestionnaires privés non
lucratifs pourront s'ils le souhaitent
en anticipé le versement
c'est un accord qui a également permis
de tracer des perspectives crucial il
s'agit ainsi désormais d'établir les
conditions de la rue valorisation selon
un calendrier pluriannuel d autres
métiers l'accompagnement du médico
social dont les situations ne sont pas
les mêmes mais qui tous jouent un rôle
indispensable dans l'accompagnement des
plus fragiles les parties prenantes
devront faire émerger des propositions
adaptées pour ces secteurs
vu nos temps la réalité les de leurs
conditions globales de rémunération et
la porte l'état apportera une
contribution financière en fonction des
propositions qui seront établies il
importe dans tous les cas que l'ensemble
des leviers soient activés pour garantir
l'attractivité des métiers du son et de
l'accompagnement il y aura un point
premier point qui sera fait avec
l'ensemble des signataires de l'accord
avant l'été mais c'est surtout d'ici
décembre
je conclu monsieur le président qu'une
conférence multipartite convient
l'ensemble des financeurs dont les
départements sera réuni pour prolonger
ces travaux voilà nous travaillons
depuis longtemps à ces sujets là et nous
allons tracer une perspective pour les
mois les mois à venir
la parole est à d'autres collègues de
jérôme bascher pour le groupe est
républicain
présidents et les ministres mes chers
collègues
quoi qu'il en coûte voilà une expression
finalement malheureuse elle pouvait
donner confiance dans une année
perturbée et le sénat en responsabilité
a répondu présent en votant les lois de
finances rectificatives de 2020 mais en
2021 en 2021 alors que la croissance est
de retour selon vos prévisions le
déficit public n'aura jamais été aussi
élevé selon vos prévisions
depuis l'après-guerre et qu'allons nous
laisser aux générations futures une
dette de la sécurité sociale qui pour la
première fois dans l'histoire sera
supérieur à la dette d'investissement
des collectivités locales alors le
ministre de l'économie nous dit il
faudra bien en finir avec le quoi qu'il
en coûte
le ministre du budget a aussi se sont
fait taper sur le mec parce qu'il faut
continuer car en même temps il y a le
grenelle de l'éducation a payé le ségur
de la santé a payé le bobo de la
sécurité les états généraux de la
justice
la loi de programmation militaire a
révisé de plus de 3 milliards par an
après 2022
après les élections évidemment la
remontée des taux d'intérêt est
peut-être un troisième plan de relance
ou un deuxième suivant les comptabilités
des uns et des autres alors ma question
est simple comment allez-vous arrêter le
quoi qu'il en coûte
autrement dit allez vous arrêter de
ruiner la france jusqu'à l'élection
présidentielle
pour vous répondre la parole au ministre
délégué chargé des petites et moyennes
entreprises monsieur alain griset
monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur mâché monsieur le
sénateur ma chère si vous voulez sans
aucun problème avec plaisir corps et ont
entendu aujourd'hui si nous n'avions pas
accompagner les entreprises quand y at
on entendu aujourd'hui si nous n'avions
pas accompagner les salariés quand il ya
tant entendu si nous n'avions pas mis
les moyens nécessaires pour soigner les
français à juste titre vous nous auriez
dit qu'il y a des faillites qui a des
gens en difficulté est que notre pays
n'a pas joué son rôle
le président de la république a décidé
de faire un choix qui d'ailleurs pas le
choix que tous les pays du monde ont
fait c'est d'accompagner les entreprises
pour permettre à notre économie d'être
le moment venu en situation de pouvoir
reprendre l'activité d'accompagner les
salariés et de soigner les français je
crois que nous pouvons en être fiers
parce que au moment où le virus commence
à être moins virulent et houle
la vaccination commence à nous permettre
d'espérer une situation sanitaire plus
satisfaisante
notre économie repart repart fort
la diminution d'emploi est moins forte
que toutes celles qui avaient été prévus
et au bout du compte le pari que nous
faisons
certes avec une dette plus importante
c'est que la croissance dans les
prochaines années nous permettra sans
augmenter les impôts de pouvoir réduire
la dette et de pouvoir faire que notre
pays aura été exemplaire pendant cette
crise sanitaire qui était terrible et
nous pourrons comparer dans les
prochaines années ce que la france a
fait les autres pays ont fait et je
crois que nous pourrons être satisfait
de ce que la france a fait
je sais la tour de cher monsieur me
disais pas totalement répondu mais ce
n'est pas grave je ne peux pas vous en
vouloir alors qu'il n'y a pas de
directives claires du gouvernement sur
le sujet simplement la situation des
finances publiques de ce pays est
exactement la même qu'avant l'arrivée en
italie de monsieur salle vide
je ne veux pas être responsable de
l'arrivée dans dix mois du de même chose
en france
si la parole est à notre collègue
stéphane aubier noire pour le groupe les
régimes
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
dès aujourd'hui les élèves de terminale
aborde les premières épreuves du
baccalauréat sous sa nouvelle version
mais pour bon nombre d'entre eux c'est
leur avenir d'études qui les angoisse
au moment où s'ouvre la phase
complémentaire d'admission sur la
plateforme parcours sup pour les
quelques cent soixante huit mille
candidats qui n'ont toujours pas de
proposition d'affectation la modalités
d'enseignement très singulière cette
année au lycée ont semble-t-il orienter
davantage les candidats vers les
filières sélectives avec par exemple +
28 % d'inscriptions en classes
préparatoires
parallèlement la comment dire la demande
de bienveillance du ministre blanc caire
a été entendu assez largement et même au
delà du raisonnable puisque certains
professeurs confie avoir très largement
sur noter durant le contrôle continu qui
pèsent si lourdement cette année
résultat de très bons élèves avec
d'excellents dossiers se trouve sans
aucune proposition d'affectation et fait
peser une suspicion quant à la
transparence du processus d'admission et
de sélection ces bons élèves à qui la
république promettait de récompenser le
mérite et le travail se trouve
totalement désemparés face à cette
situation qu'ils estiment évidemment
injuste mais madame la ministre
ma question est donc autant celle des
candidats que des familles les critères
académiques sont ils toujours
prépondérant dans la presse dans les
processus d'admission parcours super
pour vous répondre
la parole est à vous mobiliser
derrière de la recherche l'innovation
modem vidal avait la parole merci
beaucoup monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur pierre noah
permettez moi de tirer profit de votre
question pourrait effectivement revenir
sur l'avancée de ce procès d'une cette
procédure est avant toute chose pour
souhaiter bonne chance à tous les jeunes
qui vont passer le baccalauréat cette
année
vous mentionnez le cas de très bons
profils qui n'auraient pas obtenu les
propositions de leur choix je crois que
c'est important de rappeler que depuis
le 27 mai tous les candidats qui n'ont
fait que des demandes dans des filières
sélectives et qui n'a obtenu aucune
réponse ont été rappelés
individuellement ont été accompagnés de
manière à ce que aujourd'hui alors que
débute justement la procédure
complémentaire ils puissent trouver à
nouveau la formation qui les intéresse
cette formation elle concerne absolument
tous les établissements des
établissements les plus sélectifs aux
établissements qui sont partout sur
l'ensemble de notre territoire et je
voudrais vraiment en profiter pour
saluer le travail formidable des
services et des équipes en ce qui
concerne les critères vous savez son
public ils sont affichés depuis 2020
chaque année les établissements publics
dans un rapport écrit terres qui ont été
utilisés et chaque jeune peut avoir
accès au motif personnel correspondant
les choix qui ont été faits pour lui et
puis permettez moi de partager aussi
avec l'ensemble du sénat un certain
nombre de chiffres qui me paraissent
intéressants et qui montre que cette
procédure nous permet enfin d'arrêter la
question de l'autocensure est au
contraire de renforcer la reconnaissance
du mérite que vous souhaitez tous ici je
le sais c'est aujourd'hui 91 7 % des
lycéens
qui préparent le bac général qui ont eu
une proposition
ces 93 % des lycéens boursiers qui
préparent le bac général 1 2 point de
plus et je crois que c'est important de
saluer cela aussi de saluer tous ces
jeunes qui ont osé cette année faire des
demandes dans notre pays la
reconnaissance du mérite est vraiment
une réalité j'en suis très fier
merci jupe le noir une mission
d'expertisé a été récemment confiée à
l'inspection générale de l'éducation
pour effectuer le suivi des voeux sur
cette session 2021 sur parcours sur la
lettre de mission qui a été signé de
votre main dans la main la ministre
demande qu'une attention toute
particulière soit apportée je cite à la
manière dont ces formations veille à
conserver dans leurs classements la
diversité de profils ainsi qu'aux
efforts qu'elles feront en matière
d'ouverture sociale et d' équilibre de
genre
cela ne peut qu'interroger madame la
ministre est-il écrit tsy ces critères
sont intégrés aux algorithmes locaux il
serait agréable que les candidats leurs
familles et pourquoi pas la
représentation nationale en soient
informés
merci monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
nous en avons terminé avec les questions
au gouvernement je vous rappelle que les
prochaines questions auront lieu
mercredi 23 juin à 15 heures j'avais
suspendre la séance et sera reprise à
16h35 pour la suite de l'examen du
projet de loi portant lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique et renforcement
de la résilience face à ses effets la
séance est suspendue
[Musique]
voilà pour ces questions d'actualité au
gouvernement que vous avez pu suivre en
direct sur public sénat et en
intégralité beaucoup de sujets ont été
évoqués comme le respect des mesures
sanitaires les moyens l'hôpital public
ou encore les états généraux de la
justice
on va tout de suite aller en salle des
conférences du sénat pour recueillir les
premières réactions après cette séance
de questions d'actualité
on va aller voir steve jourdain qui est
avec hervé marseille le président du
groupe centriste au sénat
oui avec hervé marseille bons joueurs
avaient marché merci d'être avec nous
ces annonces de jean castex sur la levée
des restrictions ce sont des bonnes
annonces vous les attendiez écoutez on
va pas bouder notre plaisir ça fait
longtemps que on attend ce moment il
arrive c'est satisfaisant je veux croire
que si le premier ministre annonce la
levée de cette interdiction c'est que
les autorités sanitaires ont j'allais
dire amener cette conclusion donc il
fait beau la vie doit reprendre bah tant
mieux si on doit plus porter le masque
c'est une bonne chose
j - 4 avant les élections régionales on
redoute une abstention massive ça serait
un nouveau coup dur à notre démocratie
si cette abstention est effectivement
avoir lieu
oui c'est à craindre élection après
élection on constate que évidemment
l'abstention crois ça veut dire que
notre démocratie est malade quelque part
ça veut dire que les gens ne croient
plus dans la parole publique et que le
fait de se déplacer pour aller voter
finalement ne les inspire pas et ils ont
le sentiment que finalement qu'il veut
tous qu'ils ne votent pas ça change pas
grand jeu leur dire vous leur dites quoi
c'est à nous de leur prouver que c'est
important d'aller voter que pour les
départementales et régionales c'est
important puisque ya des compétences qui
les concernent au quotidien et que on a
la chance de dans un pays démocratique
ce n'est pas si courant que ça dans le
monde et que se déplacer pour aller
voter c'est important
il ya des gens qui meurent pour avoir le
droit d'aller voter chez nous on a pris
cette habitude on peint on va il fait
beau alors on va pas voter
ça peut se comprendre mais c'est pas bon
pour notre démocratie
il ya beaucoup de choses dans
l'actualité à marseille vous étiez je
crois hier à l'élysée à l'elysée où
emmanuel macron à décorer edouard
philippe pour son passage par matignon
ça s'est passé comment sympathiquement
on était surtout qu'est ce qui s'est dit
bon écoute et des choses j'allais dire
très banal c'est à dire que le président
de la république a fait l'éloge du
récipiendaire d'edouard philippe et il a
énuméré toutes les raisons pour
lesquelles il mérité cette distinction
il a même ajouté que c'était pour ses
mérites passé et peut-être pour ses
mérites futures ont peut-être une
candidature peut-être peut-être hervé
marseille petite dernière question vous
êtes convoqué avec marseille cet été
emmanuel macron a pris un décret de
convocation du parlement pour le mois de
juillet entrée à prendre en principe le
parlement devait mettre fin à ses
travaux fin juin finalement ce sera fin
juillet ça devient l'habitude la session
est de moins en moins extraordinaire est
de plus en plus ordinaire et à trop de
texte il faut qu'on puisse travailler
plus sereinement
en tous les cas ce sont des textes
importants il faut nous donner à nous
comme à l'assemblée le temps de travail
et ses textes si on veut que on est des
lois qu'ils soient importantes qu'ils
soient bien travaillé et qui signifie
quelque chose si je dirigeais les la
quinzaine de textes qui vont être
examinés vont être à clé en quelque
sorte pas bâcler parce qu'on essaie de
faire notre travail nous comme à
l'assemblée
simplement il faut avoir le temps de
pouvoir aller travailler au fond en
commission en assemblée et on manque
cruellement de temps merci beaucoup
hervé marseille merci d'avoir répondu
aux micros de public sénat aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup steve pour cette
interview d'hervé marseille président du
groupe centriste au sénat et steve on va
vous retrouver en salle des conférences
puisque à votre micro il ya maintenant
la ministre sarah et la grille en charge
de la jeunesse
oui bonjour madame la ministre merci
d'être avec nous fin du port du masque
obligatoire en extérieur à partir de
demain fin du couvre feu à partir de
dimanche c'est aussi un message envoyé
aux plus jeunes qui en ont un peu ras le
bol de ce couvre-feu
ce sont de bonnes
l on retrouve une vie qui ressemble
évidemment les étapes son avance d'abord
cette fin de couvre-feu c'est l'occasion
de retrouver évidemment à l'extérieur
des espaces de convivialité tout en
respectant toujours un maximum de
précautions et ce sont de bonnes
nouvelles c'est grâce évidemment la
vigilance de tous nouveaux à prendre à
ceux qui disent que vous avez cédé un
peu la pression populaire
vous savez il ya je veux dire il faut
pas aller chercher la petite polémique
ou houleux le commentaire le plus grave
ça fait du bien je crois que c'est
important ça fait plus d'un an et demi
que tout le monde fait des efforts que
tout le monde et les jeunes en
particulier
eh bien ce sont restreints ont respecté
les règles énormément et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il est temps de les
saluer et permettre à la vie de
reprendre et bien et de vivre cet été le
plus normalement possible
madame la ministre la vaccination est
ouverte aux ados de 12 entre 12 et 18
ans depuis hier est ce que sa mort à ce
que les jeunes se précipitent vers les
centres de vaccination à ce que vous en
quelques chiffres déjà oui se trouve que
le vaccin créer un vrai engouement chez
les plus jeunes parce que le vaccin ça
veut dire un retour à la vie à la vie à
la normale ça veut dire partir en
vacances ça veut dire partir en colo est
évidemment les parents restent la règle
du consentement des parents mais vous ne
sentez pas de réticence non il ya plutôt
une envie est d'ailleurs une envie assez
assez dynamique autour de gourmandises
au retour de la vie normale les jeunes
sont pas les personnes plus âgées c'est
ce que ça aurait pas été finalement plus
judicieux de donner ses doses à des pays
plus pop test aurait permis de freiner
l'épidémie au niveau mondial aujourd'hui
l'action de la france à l'étranger et
vis-à-vis de la solidarité nationale est
réel et les fermes
elle est forte protéger et vacciné les
plus jeunes c'est aussi permettre
d'attendre cette immunité collective il
faut le rappeler
les plus jeunes sont effectivement moins
sensibles aux conséquences sauf qu'il y
à des cas graves est aujourd'hui se
faire vacciner quand on entre 12 et 18
ans et se protéger soi c'est protéger
les autres et surtout permettre un
retour de vie à la normale ça râle
aillerie vous lancer à partir de lundi
prochain le service national universel
s'adresse aux jeunes entre 15 et 18 ans
en quoi ça consistait ce que ça va
vraiment permettre de refaire nation
commandiez maintenant dès lundi presque
vingt mille jeunes vont se retrouver
partout en france
dans tous les départements de france il
y aura un centre d'accueil de ce genre
de cohésion oui ça permet de recréer du
lien refaire nation pourquoi parce que
ce sont des jeunes qui viennent de
plusieurs territoires
ils viennent de familles différentes
idées de parcours différent c'est des
jeunes qui ne se seraient jamais
croisées en dehors c'est 18 le 20 mille
jeunes qui vont se retrouver
eh bien ils vont vivre des temps
républicain des rituels lever de drapeau
le chant de la marseillaise faire du
sport ensemble manger ensemble débattre
discuter pas servir light en quelque
sorte c'est le meilleur du service
militaire le meilleur de la colonne
vacances et le meilleur de l'école c'est
en réalité est le meilleur des trois et
c'est pour ça qu'il ya eu plus de
demandes en réalité que de que de places
disponibles
mais vous savez que ce projet tient
énormément au président de la république
c'est une volonté forte
nous avons vocation évidemment elle
généralisée dans les années qui arrivent
mais déjà dès lundi ça sera plus de
18000 volontaires qui vont se retrouver
c'est une chance pour nos territoires et
c'est une chance pour ces jeunes
merci beaucoup madame la ministre merci
d'avoir répondu aux questions de public
sénat j'ai cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement j'ai cru
annick billon bonjour sénatrice
centriste de vendée présidente de la
délégation aux droits des femmes du
sénat
j'accueille également david assouline
bonjour bonjour vous êtes sénateur
socialiste de paris
on va parler du respect des mesures
sanitaires de l'allègement de ses
mesures sanitaires qui a été annoncé cet
après midi par jean castex mais ce
respect des mesures sanitaires c'était
aussi un sujet de la séance de questions
d'actualité
cet après midi on va voir ça avec
quentin qu'elle mais qui en tribune de
presse de l'hémicycle du sénat il ya
notamment une question du sénateur
républicain fabien genêt ouais tout à
fait effectivement alex avec des
sénateurs qui ont pu c'est vrai poser
des questions sur ce couvre-feu
suspendues à partir de dimanche et bien
seulement deux heures après l annonce ce
qui en a été fait et les sénateurs qui
il faut le dire était est très critique
il avait prévu ces questions avant même
l'annoncé de jean castex sur les
notamment les les incohérences des
derniers jours sur ce sur ce couvre-feu
3 écouter le sénateur jeunes et qui
effectivement posé la question
son point de départ si ce qui s'est
passé à roland garros la semaine
dernière vendredi soir
tandis que mes concitoyens de digoin en
saône-et-loire respectait
scrupuleusement le couvre-feu et
quittait la terrasse du dock 713
guinguette en bord de loire à 23h au
même moment les privilégiés des loges de
roland garros scandaient merci macro
merci macron en hommage à celui qui les
avait autorisés à ne pas respecter le
couvre feu
et puis ce week end nos concitoyens ont
vu en boucle les images de vos ministres
ils ont vu votre ministre délégué à
l'intérieur chanter en meeting sur une
estrade sans masque et c'était sans
compter sans votre ministre de la
justice qui malheureusement à court
d'arguments n'avait plus que ses
postillons à offrir contre scène son
adversaire identitaire le garde des
sceaux
le garde des sceaux n'ayant pas jugé bon
de garder son masque
cette phrase a beaucoup fait réagir je
vous le cache pas on pouvait voir d'ici
le banc des ministres et on a vu tous
les yeux se lever deux des dossiers pour
regarder pièce qui était en train de
parler sur ce ton et on a senti par
exemple garde des sceaux a passablement
irrité par cette remarque c'est donc
gérald darmanin le miso intérieur qui a
répondu à ces sénateurs et l'air écoutez
le et je veux vous dire que nous avons
pris avec constituent des quels que
soient des classes sociales puisque vous
les posez ainsi vous trempez ont sans
doute un peu de groupes politiques sans
doute effectivement l'accès à des règles
sanitaires respecté et respectable
alors monsieur le sénateur en vous
écoutant en vous écoutant cesser la
politique des grincheux et soyez heureux
d'être en france et pour une fois une
fois ça changera rien aux élections ni
départementales et régionales et
présidentielle- avouer que nous avons
tenu la baraque et français peuvent en
des siennes voilà et certains sénateurs
qui ensuite dans les autres questions
ont repris cette expression des
grincheux et qui a été employé par
gérald darmanin on retiendra aussi à
remercier un que micro de steve jourdain
vient de dire qu'il ne fallait pas que
nous cachions notre plaisir sur ce sujet
avec merci beaucoup
quentin est ce qu'il faut se réjouir de
l'allègement des mesures sanitaires de
la fin du couvre-feu à 23h à partir de
dimanche prochain également de la fin de
l'obligation de porter le masque en
extérieur david assouline est ce qu'il
nous faut il faut être grincheux prudent
vis-à-vis de cet allègement des mesures
sanitaires
non moi je suis très content j'ai je
pense que je n'ose même pas imaginer que
le gouvernement puisse dire ça alors que
ya un risque et que mais j'ose pas
imaginer non plus qu'il a devancé ce qui
était prévu puisque on nous avait
annoncé que ce serait le 30 janvier
parce que il ya une année des élections
ce week-end et la semaine suivante
voilà donc je moi je suis content je
pense que si ça a été un peu de vent
c'est quand même je vais répondre à la
question même si c'est pour le bien de
tout le monde ce n'est pas par hasard et
je pense que ça un petit goût d'anciens
politiciens et électoralistes quand même
c'est une tactique politique d'annoncer
la fin du couvre-feu à quatre jours d'un
scrutin électoral anime bien moi je me
réjouis de la levée du couvre-feu je me
réjouis de ne plus avoir à porter le
masque à l'extérieur à partir de demain
et je me réjouis pourquoi le masque
s'affadir de demain couvre feu c'est à
partir de demain david rihs et et
pourquoi je me réjouis bien parce que ça
veut dire que la situation sanitaire en
france elle s'améliore
on est à un taux d'incidence de 50 pour
cent mille ça veut dire que la la
pandémie la crise sanitaire
on arrive à un moment où on a
l'impression qu'elle est un peu plus
derrière nous il faut rester vigilant
mais c'est une grande satisfaction
alors je ne rentrerai pas dans la mode
polémique moi le masque avec 34 degrés
comme à paris cette semaine
je suis ravi de le retirer et c'est une
bonne nouvelle et je pense que les
français vont être extrêmement
satisfaits de cette nouvelle mais oui
avec l'été qui arrive
david assouline cet allègement des
mesures sanitaires est ce que c'est
au final un succès de la stratégie d'
emmanuel macron de trouver un compromis
entre garantie des libertés impératifs
sanitaires dans cette crise pourquoi ce
serait
un succès ou un échec c'est c'est ce qui
était prévu avec l'effort des français
puisque il a fallu effectivement accepté
beaucoup de contraintes de de
restriction de nos libertés
individuelles les français l'ont
supportait mal à beaucoup de gens qui
disaient que ce peuple ne ne savait pas
disciplinés quand il le fallait non
voilà la cause en valait la chandelle
donc je veux surtout salué le fait que
ce qui était prévu et qui est mondial et
qui est européen comme moment de décrue
avec me félicite aussi que la campagne
de vaccination est pas mal marché espère
que l'intensité va continuer parce que
certains disent que ben ça commence à
baisser que beaucoup de rendez vous ne
sont pas honorées dans beaucoup de de
centre puis maintenant on va aussi
croiser les doigts c'est à dire que la
prudence est importante puisque le
conseil scientifique lui même lit
attention en septembre il peut y avoir
aussi une nouvelle vague
et donc voilà je j'ai la satisfaction
aussi je suis très heureux qu'on ne
porte pas de masque à cette question que
j'ai posée c'est que à quatre jours près
il ya quand même une élection c'est tout
et que ça changeait rien à notre bonheur
d'ailleurs que ce soit le 30 juin je
trouvais ça déjà très bien
certains disaient c'est un peu trop tôt
quand quand le ministre annonçait que ce
serait le 30 juin nous étions très
heureux
alors ça a été devancé on est tous
heureux il faut effectivement je pense
pas que c'est complètement étranger à
des quelques on va voir ce qu'en pensent
les membres de la communauté de gens m'a
scié notre streamer politique sur la
plateforme
twitch genre est ce qu'il a été question
de cet allègement des mesures sanitaires
durant cette séance de questions
d'actualité sur twitter eh bien écoutez
intéresserait les les internautes
évidemment sur les quais sur les
questions sanitaires ça a fait mal
réagir les propositions de jean castex
également il ya notamment un succès qui
a beaucoup intéressé les internautes
c'est la question
la question était posée par le sénateur
jockey son nom c'était fabien genêt la
fameuse question roland garros c'est
vrai que le deux poids deux mesures
réagir les internautes
les spectateurs de roland-garros sur ton
pc à rester après 23 heures dans
operation au même moment sur les plus
insolites se faisait se faisait avec des
actes prochaine c'est vrai que ça a
beaucoup fait réagir cette question de
jeu fabien genêt pardon les sénateurs
des républicains à vous internautes la
réponse tarde maintenant beaucoup mes
tétons un petit peu à côté de la plaque
et ça ça fait réagir en mauvais sens
ceci étant il ya aussi actions peu du
sénateur écologiste salle pons sur la
fuite du nucléaire en chine qui a reposé
la question
le p r de flamanville la france est elle
était le niveau en matière de sécurité
nucléaire
ça aussi en doute sa peau pour réagir et
s'implante sur sur le tchat
la réponse est daniel wagon chargé
développement était là aussi un petit
peu à côté de la plaque pas ce critère
elle s'est contentée de rappeler la
signification du mix énergétique en kg
par la loi de programmation et la
pratique voilà ces sujets merci beaucoup
jean annick billon je voudrais vous
faire réagir ce que vous aussi vous avez
été choqué ce week-end par ces images de
spectateurs de roland garros qui
finalement une d une dérogation pour le
couvre-feu donne elle parle pas présents
la république et en même temps ces
jeunes aux invalides qui sont et bien
évacuée manu militari par les policiers
ou même dans d'autres territoires du
pays
je crois vraiment que le port du masque
devenait extrêmement difficile à faire
respecter qui a eu une à laisser passer
on va dire pour les spectateurs de
roland garros à partir de ce moment là
évidemment c'était plus difficile de
l'imposer à d'autres par contre je
autant je suis persuadé que la
vaccination permet véritablement
d'avancer vers une immunité collective
autant la levée du port de masque du
port du masque et la levée plus tôt le
du couvre feu
je ne pense pas que ça va avoir une
incidence réelle sur la participation
aux élections du week-end prochain
si ça devait être le cas s'il accepte
tensions devaient être réduites de ce
fait écoute tant mieux si ça doit
mobiliser
la participation non non j'ai très bien
compris je tourne et à mon avantage la
remarque de notre collègue david
assouline
bon moi je pensais quand même un message
envoyé à la jeunesse est pas que c'était
un collègue
je ne connaissais pas soutien du
gouvernement mais nous l'annoncent ce
soir c'était goûter que les choses
soient claires bien sûr que c'est
choquant pas la dérogation c'est que si
on décide qui puis qu'on peut avoir ce
type de 2,2 de dérogation à ce moment là
on le fait pour d'autres et bien sûr à
ce qui était très je vois là il faut des
règles dans le pays
et c'est pas possible il y avait un truc
fou c'est que derrière on a mis en
parallèle le fait qu' il ya eu un
avertissement du gouvernement que du pur
hier le match france allemagne
il fallait bien rentrer chez soi à temps
et donc quitté avant la fin du match les
cafés etc où on était puisque après le
match fini vers 11 heures
bon après 11h 22h50 donc bon et ça
c'était choquant parce que via ce média
il ya dérogation pour france à la fin
peut plus demande concernés et le foot
est un sport populaire et c'est
justement où il ya tout le monde qui
communient et et après le vraiment voulu
éteindre la polémique en disant mais
nous demanderons aux forces de l'autre
un peu de mardi c'est la reine mais on
dit aux policiers ne fait pas respecter
la règle mais bon franchement c'est ça
qui rend un peu folle la société c'est à
dire que s'il ya des rennes et des
valeurs partagées
qu'on soit riche ou pauvre tout ce que
l'on veut et bien c'est cela qu'on
apprend aux élèves y compris pour dans
la classe c'est pas possible qu'au plus
haut niveau on soit dans le n'importe
quoi on va parler d'un autre sujet de
votre calendrier parlementaire chargé
notamment pour le mois de juillet
puisqu'il y aura une section session
extraordinaire avec beaucoup de textes
on va aller en salle des conférences
retrouver steve jours d'un quai à son
micro à philippe bas wifi bas bonjour
vous êtes convoqué chili bat vous êtes
convoqué parce qu emmanuel macron a pris
un décret de convocation du parlement à
partir du 1er juillet session
extraordinaire du parlement jusqu'à la
fin juillet alors il faut rappeler qu'en
théorie le parlement devait siéger
jusqu'à la fin juin mais cette
prolongation ça devient un peu une
habitude c'est un non-événement
finalement non c'est un non événement
dans la mesure où c'est vrai nous
légiférons régulièrement au mois de
juillet ce qui est un événement en
revanche c'est de voir le menu est là
c'est presque extravagants on va tout de
même pas réglé au mois de juillet de
tout ce qui n'a pas pu être fait dans
les quatre années précédentes puis
d'ailleurs je signale qu on a encore
quelques mois pour discuter de projets
de loi importants
je ne méconnais pas l'importance des
textes pour certains d'entre eux qui
sont inscrits à cette session
extraordinaire mais je crois que nous ne
pouvons pas travailler nous au parlement
comme si nous étions dans une seringue
ça c'était une quinzaine de textes je
crois qu'ils vont être examinés ce que
voulait dire c'est que travailler dans
l'urgence c'est pas possible pas chacun
peut se rendre compte que si on respecte
le parlement et si nous voulons que le
parlement vote la loi après des
discussions approfondies un travail qui
nous permettent aussi d'auditionner
toutes les personnes compétentes
ça demande un peu de temps et qu' il ne
faut pas forcer le passage à tout prix
d'ailleurs vous fais le pari que sur
cette liste de textes qui est un petit
peu un inventaire à la prévert il faudra
bien s'accommoder du fait que la
discussion ne pourra pas aller au bout
dès le mois de juillet et qu'il faudra
continuer le travail et c'est bien ainsi
qu'est ce que ça veut dire que ça ne
pourra pas à ce sujet on pourra pas
adopter quinze lois dont certaines sont
très importantes en volume m en l'espace
de trois semaines du mois de juillet de
l'année 2020 t1 le temps parlementaire
doit être respectée nous ne rechignons
pas à la tâche
nous retroussons nos manches et pas
seulement au mois de juillet tout le
reste de l'année
il faut prendre le temps de la
délibération c'est comme ça qu'une
démocratie respire et qu'un exécutif
mais ne gouverne pas le pays avec les
pleins pouvoirs il faut le tenir compte
de la représentation nationale
nous sommes enracinés dans les
territoires députés et sénateurs mais
particulièrement les sénateurs nous
représentons les français nous sommes au
contact des français
nous portons au parlement leur voix face
au projet du gouvernement pour les
améliorer et faire en sorte qu'il y ait
des bonnes lois pour pas en changer tous
les 4 matins vous avez remarqué
peut-être qu'on a fait au mois de
janvier une loi sur l'économie
circulaire et qu'on est en train de
passer notre temps depuis lundi au sénat
le texte à la corriger parce que le
gouvernement a repris plus ou moins sans
filtre les propositions de la soi-disant
convention citoyenne et que donc une loi
à peine promulguée avec la signature du
président de la république la loi
la blague lancre de la loi à peine sèche
on nous demande déjà de la modifier
alors si c'est pour faire ce genre de
travail dans la précipitation
moi je réponds excusez moi mais je ne
suis pas là pour ça merci beaucoup
philippe bas merci d'avoir répondu
au micro de bmx et la merci beaucoup
steve pour cette réaction
annick billon le gouvernement surcharge
le calendrier parlementaire de juillet
c'est un manque de respect du parlement
c'est surtout une difficulté
supplémentaire pour aborder des textes
majeurs en un temps record comme vient
de le préciser philippe bas le temps
long permet parfois d'éviter des écueils
je reprendrai à mon compte les mots du
président mon président hervé marseille
tout à l'heure qui disait que la session
extraordinaire au prg allait plus
c'était plus utiliser plus synonyme de
session ordinaire que deux sessions
extraordinaires donc évidemment oui on a
besoin de temps on a besoin de temps
pour élaborer la loi pour faire un
travail en amont
et là on le voit depuis de nombreux mois
le temps nous manque c'est à dire que
lorsque vous avez par exemple pour le
projet de loi climat plus de mille
amendements à étudier dans un temps
record pour la par la commission du
développement durable de jean françois
longeot c'est quand même difficile
d'avancer de manière structurée et aussi
de manière réfléchie
il faut le temps pour les auditions il
faut temps pour la réflexion et ce temps
là nous ne l'avons pas donc c'est
effectivement très dommage
david assouline en même temps ça se
comprend et bientôt dans la dernière
année du quinquennat il faut faire
passer les lois donc le calendrier se
change en surcharge
il ya maintenant ce que c'est il n'y a
rien d'exceptionnel dans ce pot fait le
gouvernement c'est depuis le début
toujours pareil et ce n'est pas que dans
ce domaine parce que vous avez une
situation où les sessions
extraordinaires
il y en a tout le temps à dire que c'est
effectivement devenue ordinaire bon ok
on va pas nous dire qu'on travaille trop
on aime ce coup fait mon travail au quai
ensuite on nous dit que tout doit passer
en urgence donc c'est même pas les
sessions extraordinaires pour nous
donner plus d'amplitude de présence pour
aller au fond des textes non aujourd'hui
nous travaillons que dans l'urgence
c'est à dire avec une lecture on enlève
un droit constitutionnel c'est dans la
constitution qui a deux lectures dans
les faits on installe une pratique
courante qui annule ce ce droit et quand
on vient d'être élu président de la
république on dit bah il faut une
session extraordinaire qui durent
longtemps en été parce qu'on vient
d'être élue faut mettre en place un
ensemble de politiques en général ça se
finit le 9 août pour partir en vacances
maintenant on nous dit c'est la dernière
année avant la lex ou présidentielle
donc il faut finir ta et vous allez voir
que c'est pas fini vous nous dire faut
rentrer tôt
donc il y aura une autre section
extraordinaire à la rentrée donc il y en
a assez c'est à dire que probablement ya
trop de lois trop doit d'initiative
gouvernementale non plus parce que si ça
venait nous mais très souvent ces
initiatives gouvernementales ce que
chaque ministre son truc et on travaille
à la schlague c'est plus possible
il ya un équilibre qui est mon pull et
les français pensent qu'on ne fait pas
grand chose de politique donc à un
moment donné il va falloir aussi mettre
en lumière que on a besoin d'être
valorisés d'être considérés et que pour
cela ça dépend où le vent là demain
toute la journée
n'en faisons des lois qui de fournissant
travailler et où des français voient un
impact sur leur vie quotidienne et c'est
ça qui les raccordera à notre travail
est à la politique ce sera le mot de la
fin est en tout cas public sénat sera là
pour faire vivre les travaux du sénat
durant tout ce mois de juillet merci
beaucoup d'avoir été sur ce plateau pour
débriefer séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
merci beaucoup d'avoir
suivi cette séance cette émission mais
restez avec nous dans un instant vous
allez pouvoir suivre l'audition du
ministre de la justice eric dupond
moretti et de la ministre de la
transformation public amélie de
montchalin une audition sur la
numérisation de la justice et sur les
moyens informatiques du personnel de
l'institution judiciaire
je vous laisse écouter cette audition
vous avertir que nous sommes